e
good morning today is Monday January 13
2025 and this is the New Hampshire House
of Representatives Municipal and County
government committee I am representative
Diane power and the committee has
convened today for the purposes of a
committee orientation That was supposed
to start at 10: followed by a public
hearing on seven bills to begin at 10:30
a.m. now please make sure that your cell
phones are silenced and please join me
in reciting the Pledge of Allegiance LED
today by the ranking member
representative
stavis i al to the flag of the United
States States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
you at this time the clerk will take
attendance
to
me
me just use that is the B oh okay you
just just call each person's name in
okay representative power
present repres uh Vice chair
McDonald
pres clerk is
present representative
Deputy
magor
pres representative Dolan
pres representative Guthrie
yeah representative Elward
presid representative Murphy pres
representative
France representative
Walker representative kinsky president
pres representative
Gilman
pres
representative
Brock present and congratulations on
pronouncing it correctly thank you sir
representative Colby present
representative
gerana
president thank you before we begin
today I have a few morning
announcements so as I announced we have
convened for orientation and public
hearings on seven bills that it is to
start at
10:30 after the public hearing schedule
for 11:20 the committee will break for
lunch and then public hearings will
resume Zoom at 1:00 until our publicly
noticed business has been completed for
the
day so in front of you in the sea of
papers that's on your table you should
orientation also as part of that packet
I have um prepared a handout entitled
instructions and checklist for
preparation of committee reports some
sample uh committee reports a handout
entitled parliamentary
inquiry and a memorandum from the New
Hampshire Association of counties we
will be going over this information
orientation so I'd like to begin with um
committee introductions
I've prepared uh an outline um as a
suggestion of um what you might want to
include in your
introduction um I'll go over it briefly
you might want to jot down a few notes
I'm going to um it would be nice to
share with everybody your name your
county that you're from and the
municipalities that you represent maybe
a sentence about your background how
long you've lived in New Hampshire the
number of terms that you've served in
the house um any past or present um
local government experience maybe why
you chose to serve on this committee so
I will go first as I said I am
representative Diane power and I will be
serving as the chair of this committee
for this
term I am from Hillsboro County District
36 and I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville my back
ground is I have a Bachelor of Science
degree in electrical engineering from
Worcester poly Technic Institute in
Worcester Mass and I am a retired
digital design engineer and Technical
instructor I have lived in New Hampshire
for 37 years this is my third term in
the New Hampshire house my third term on
this committee last term I had the
privilege of serving as the vice
chairman my past local government
experience includes I was elected to a
Cooperative School District budget
committee where I served as the chair
and a member and I have also volunteered
in my town of Brookline in the food
pantry as well as in the public schools
in various roles and why did I choose to
um put down municip and County
government as my committee Choice
freshman year it was my second choice
I put down Education First I'm glad I
didn't get assigned to education but
I've um I do have a keen interest in
Municipal
law so next um we're just going to
follow the the list here on the
orientation next I'd like the our vice
chairman uh representative McDonald to
introduce
[Music]
himself uh good morning everyone my name
is John McDonald uh been a member of the
uh legislature since 2018 and I've been
on this committee the entire time I
think it's probably the best committee
uh out of all the Committees that we
have in the New Hampshire house but I'm
a little biased I served as clerk for uh
four years and I was fortunate enough to
be asked to uh take over the assistant
um Chairman's uh Chairman's job um I
have a bachelor's degree in criminal
justice I have a law degree from
Massachusetts school of law I retire
died from the New Hampshire state police
after 30-year career and uh for the past
couple years I've been representing
clients in China and
Vietnam uh which is a very unique
representation to
represent um I'm on the T of wolfa
budget committee I'm the chairman been
on that committee for about 35 years and
I look forward to working with you folks
this year thank
you thank you representative McDonald
next we have our clerk representative
good morning um my name is Marie Bell um
this is my first term in the house and
my first term on this committee this
committee was uh one of my top three
choices to be serving on and I'm very
proud to be here um my background is I
have a currently have a doctorate in
physical therapy and I do uh I currently
run a private practice in um in north
havil um not much of a political career
really but getting involved this year I
am on the executive committee for
Grafton County and uh we we we're going
to do a lot of work with the budget for
the county and uh the reason why I am
run I ran for office and gratefully that
I won was just to uh give back to the
community that gave me so much in my
practice I miss
thank you thank you representative next
we have the ranking member
representative
stavis thank you madam chair my name is
Laurel stavis I represent Grafton up uh
313 which is the city of Lebanon a city
of some 14 to 15,000 people during the
day and which balloons to about 60,000
people when everybody shows up to work
at Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center
I have been in the legislature since
2018 I have only been on this committee
represented McDonald said he thinks this
is the best Committee in the house
whereas I know this is the best
Committee in the house um feel strongly
about the importance of Municipal and
County government as a foundation of how
things are
run um in New Hampshire and I served on
the Lebanon planning board for eight
maybe n n years I'm now currently a
member of the West Lebanon
revitalization advisory committee I have
a degree in music from the New England
Conservatory of Music and I have been in
administrative roles in higher education
both at Welsley college and most
recently at Dartmouth College where I
initiatives thank you representative
stavis next next we have our Deputy
ranking member representative
majori thank you madam chair and
congratulations um my name is Jim majori
I represent the seaside community of
Northampton which is Rockingham
23 um where I have been on the select
board for fifth this is my 15th year on
the select board and three years on the
budget committee before that where I
also serve as the representative to the
planning board the Heritage commission
and the Water Commission so there was a
natural inclination to want to come to
Municipal and County government where I
have been uh for now all four terms that
I have been in the house and do agree
that uh this committee is very effective
in uh very very effective very cordial
and and we've always had great
relationships and I have every
expectation that that's going to
continue um I'm I'm always impressed at
the uh at the education and the level of
expertise of everybody here which which
blends well to the to the important
legislation um because while we might
not be on the back page of the paper and
we might not be the lead story for Mu
are we are what happens when when you go
home and pay your taxes uh we are what
happens when you drive down your roads
uh we are the everyday in your community
so I I have a great passion for what we
do here and I look forward to the work
together thank
you thank you representative majori next
we have representative Dolan
thank you madam
chair my name is Tom Dolan I'm from
London Derry this is my fourth term in
the
legislature um I served six terms uh on
the Town Council in London Derry uh one
term as a budget committee uh member uh
Municipal and County was my first choice
to come back to I I I served as a
ranking member of this uh of this
committee
as a freshman uh then uh served as the
chair of the committee after that went
on to the chair of a uh a special
committee on Commissions in the and uh
asked the speaker if he would put me
back on this Committee in my fourth term
um I'm a a West Point grad uh I serve I
serve my country uh starting back in the
7s uh ended up also with a a graduate
degree uh from Pepperdine University so
I'm I'm well aware of the geography of
the current emergency in California with
the fires going on peppard's right right
in the middle of that area uh and I look
forward to working with you all and I'm
glad to be back on the best
committee thank you representative Dolan
um next we have representative Guthrie
to introduce
himself thank you Mr chair Madam
chairman uh my name is Joe gri I
represent the town of
Hamstead uh Rockingham
um i' I've been around for a long while
probably been involved in local
government for at least 60
years um mainly because I think I was
the youngest person elected school
committee back in Massachusetts to come
from not an Mass where I served on the
board of SL in addition to the school
committee then I moved out to the great
state of New Hampshire and ran for SEL
and I've been to select been on and off
uh for something like nine or 10 years
uh I had a break back in the
90s uh I was a state ref and my wife got
very sick and uh I had to be a kid taker
so that was an experience un fortunately
we
uh so I went back and got busy again and
I'm still currently a
selectman uh in the H that I have the
honor if there is an honor to be the
oldest R of the house and I ask you to
be nice to me just because of my age so
if I say what what a couple of times I
hope you can can appreciate that um I've
also served on the uh planning board uh
the board of selectman
uh in Hamstead as I said and uh I I I'm
so glad to be on this committee as Jim
has said earlier that this is the
committee that has a real impact on
local government uh so uh but whatever
we do for good or for bad uh and we have
back on a local government and I'm glad
to be here I see a lot of new faces and
I welcome you all and I hope you enjoy
the
session thank you representative
Guthrie representative Elward is
next thank you Madame chairman my name
is Deborah L word like the L word um it
doesn't look like that in writing but
that's how it's pronounced I'm a native
of Washington DC when living inside the
Beltway became
intolerable I had the opportunity to
come to New Hampshire in
2006 and help build a house on 5 Acres
so I'm now living a rural
lifestyle um local control was a shock
to me uh completely unfamiliar with this
process um I came from Regional services
to town services
um I'm a retired private investigator
and detective agency owner I was a high
specialist in missing children
investigations um I've chose well my
past government experience was when I
was appointed to uh the Private Security
Services Advisory Board to the
Commonwealth of Virginia Criminal
Justice
Services um
department so it was a license to
Snoop um um I chose and there was a lot
to Snoop about in in in these small
towns so I chose not to serve locally
because I felt I'd be more effective as
a citizen activist and I I have done so
and have affected major changes in in
town government um
happenings and I'm serving my second
term on this committee it's a it's a
wonderful group of people and um welcome
everybody hope to get make your personal
acquaintance here
soon thank you representative Elward
next we have representative
Murphy good morning Madam chair my name
is Dennis Murphy I am from I'm a new
member Shire 11 which represents the
town of Winchester only I have a BS from
the University of LOL in
Plastics I was a Plastics process
process engineer before I retired I am
been a town moderator since 2014 and I
lived in New Hampshire for 20 years
now married for almost
51 thank you thank you representative
Murphy representative France will you
introduce
yourself thank you madam chair um my
name is Linda France I come from
Wentworth I represent Grafton district 6
which is Wentworth Romney and Orford
um my past experience has been in
accounting Administration Finance um
from Massachusetts I grew up there
retired up here in New Hampshire at um
in 2014 so I've been here for a while
and after retirement my town was in a
bit of trouble administratively as far
as not having help so of course I
volunteered and stayed there two years
as their administrator and learned a lot
about uh municipal government and that's
why I chose this committee and I'm
looking forward to working with you all
thank you thank you repres
representative
France and representative Walker you're
next thank you madam chairman my name is
David Walker I am from Rochester
been born and raised in New Hampshire
all my life been in Rochester for 38 40
years I'm a retired uh engineering
supervisor from Prat Whitney
aircraft uh I've served in the Rochester
city council since 1995 so I got over 30
years of experience in city council I
was the mayor for one term two years in
2003 and on my form I when I'm selecting
committees I put municipal government
municipal government municipal
government I got it so here I am thank
you thank you representative Walker and
to finish off on that side of the table
we have representative
kazinski thank you madam chair my name
is Sly Kosinski I'm uh from Swansea and
I've lived in chesher county for 35
years
um serving out my third term as Swansea
selectman and I'm representing chesher
district 10 which is Richmond and
Swansea
work for the north Swansea water and
fire Precinct as a superintendent it's a
village District within the town of
Swansea and I'm a former Fire Chief and
assistant moderator in town and
I Municipal and County was one of my
three top choices and here I am first
year thank you thank you representative
kazinski and next we have representative
Gilman thank you Madame chair I'm Julie
Gilman I'm represent uh Rockingham
District 11 which is the town of exitor
ex is where I was born and raised um I'm
serving my fifth term here uh I've also
served or finishing up my 18th year on
the select board in exiter and through
that experience I've worked with the
planning board the zoning board the
various various and Sury other boards
and committees that we've set up or
established um I've worked with our
economic development director on some of
the Innovative uh development laws that
we have here in New Hampshire and on the
master plan committee that we updated
just a few years ago um I have a degree
in architecture from the Rhode Island
School of Design and I look forward to
working with you all this is as
representative majori said always a an
interesting and uh very con
conversational group thank you
thank you representative Gilman
representative
frock good morning I'm David fra or
frock to pronounce it
correctly um I represent Grafton 16
which is the town of Enfield I've lived
in Enfield since about
2009 um serve serving currently on the
Enfield planning board uh which I've
chaired for probably six or seven
years also uh co-chaired our Master
planning taskforce which
has uh completed the first update to the
town's master plan in about 25
years um government experience I've been
on land use boards both here in New
Hampshire and in Vermont for a total of
I think about 25
years um I seem to have become uh very
interested in land use laws and how they
affect the people in general
development excuse
me and um hope to be able to
continue to maintain local control in
the state of New
Hampshire uh work history and education
history I have a degree in Psychology
from Western Reserve University when it
was still named
that um professionally I have been
involved in professional
communication as a producer of
multi-image and computer generated
slides and most recently large format
printing including banners posters trade
show display blazs etc etc I still keep
a few clients and uh between that and
this committee and my duties in town I'm
a busy
person thank you thank you
representative frock and next to
introduce themsel is representative
Colby hello uh I'm Elena kby I am
representing my first term uh from Bo
and Hopkinton I've lived in BO for 21
years I'm serving my first term um on
the B select board and I sit as Vice
chair currently I am a certified New
Hampshire Public
supervisor um I sit on Hazard mitigation
Heritage budget committee uh my business
background is in automotive management I
have a passion for uh local government
um even watching other communities
select board meetings for
fun uh public service is a passion I
started off as a PTO president of
baseball coach uh baseball league
president and as we all know uh you just
pick up more positions as you go along
uh so I'm happy to be here thank you
very
much thank you representative Colby and
next we have representative
ger thank you madam chair yeah I'm Dylan
germana uh representing chesher ju and
Kean where I've lived for 18 of my 21
years so far so ever since I can
remember um for my background um I'm
also a market leader for Jersey Mike so
I oversee our stores up here in New
Hampshire I'm also serving my first term
on the Keen School Board um and yeah
that's all I
got thank you repres representative
Gera and next we have representative
Gerard thank you madam chair my name is
Dale Gerard I'm representing salivan
District six which covers the towns of
Claremont and croen uh I have an
Associates in business as well as my
paramedic certificate I'm a lifelong
resident in the state of New Hampshire
uh this is my first term under the for
the New Hampshire state representatives
I'm a third term city counselor and my
second term as mayor in the community I
originally became involved through the
airport advisory and planning board
climate Development Authority uh so I've
been involved with quite a few different
items in this community thank you thank
you representative J and last but not
least representative grund thank you
madam chair my name is Stephanie grund I
represent Hillsboro 34 which is the town
of Amherst um background I have a
Bachelor of Science from Case Western
Reserve University wow yes he this is
case West Reserve is what Western
Reserve College came became um so I
worked in public accounting for about
five and a half years I went to
multinational companies and worked on
SEC reporting and some financing um
moved to New Hampshire 20 years ago and
this is my first term I've uh been a
Girl Scout volunteer I volunteered in
the schools I'm currently chair of soan
school board and work closely with our
Selectmen on um CIP issues even zoning
and planning we talk about a lot when
we're building new schools so this is a
big interest of mine as well thank you
thank you representative grund that
concludes our introduction of committee
members next next I would like to
introduce to the committee our committee
staff the director of house committee
Services is Ann Fitzgerald and I don't
see
her and
um so next I would like to
welcome committee our committee
you hi everyone I'm Jamie Wyman I am the
comme assistant nonpartisan staff
employee for municipal as well as the
other five committees that meet on this
side of the hallway so you'll be seeing
scheduling notices From Me based on the
chair's request um I maintain the
permanent record for all of the bills
that are in Municipal as well as the
rest of the committee committees on this
side of the hallway so if you ever need
anything whether that be a copy of a
voting sheet um testimony any of that
sort of stuff I keep that on record um
um I essentially ensure that all
committee related information is
accurately listed in the calendars in
the folders that then are shipped off to
archives and posted on the Committee
future thank you Jamie yeah you're
welcome I do now see um an Fitzgerald
the director of HCS would you like to
say a few
thank you
an and finally for our committee staff
we have Christy oser the committee
researcher
thank you Christie and with that that
concludes our introductions now the the
chair has managed to um schedule things
such that we are now behind schedule so
I
will continue and try to be as um quick
as I can um with regards to going over
information for the committee
orientation you have the handout in
front of you I did spend quite am amount
a bit of time um preparing this for you
it's pretty self-explanatory I will go
through it very quickly if you have any
questions please don't hesitate to
contact me or or ask me for
clarifications so committee meetings
notices are for meetings will be sent to
you by in your legislative email by the
committee assistant you can also find
the committee Public Notices for our
committee meetings they will be
published weekly in the house calendar
you may have also requested for a hard
copy to be um to be mailed to you by the
house clerk Additionally you can find
this information
online on at the web New Hampshire
joural Court website the digital
calendar and this information is also
displayed on the lob
monitors please understand that each
member is personally responsible for
obtaining this information and and being
here when we're scheduled to meet
currently we will be meeting once a week
at present uh it's looking like it will
be Mondays based on the availability of
this room however additional days of the
week maybe Tuesdays Wednesdays or
Thursdays may be required for us to meet
in order to meet house deadlines we will
be starting uh typically at 9:30 or 10
depending upon the day of the week that
we will meet I will plan to give you all
um a I'd like to do a Lun a full hour
lunch break um typically beginning
around the time that we end the bill
that is scheduled before noon um based
on our schedule so committee business
will continue then after lunch until all
our publicly noticed work has been
completed for the day and um also note
that start break and end times might
need to be adjusted to accommodate the
workload in front of us importantly um
each member of the committee has been
assigned a file cabinet draw
the cabinets located over there in our
committee room and that is for your
personal use coat racks are located
throughout the L please don't um be
hanging large bulky coats off of your
committee chairs decorum that's going to
be very important in this committee
please ensure that all cell phones and
electronic devices are silenced while in
this committee and refrain from using
electronic devices unless it's for
committee purposes like taking notes or
researching I don't want to find out
that somebody has posted on social media
that representative Powers husband is
testifying and his tie is
outdated so additionally sidebar
conversations with committee members and
cross talk shall not be permitted
committee members and members of the
public shall be recognized by the chair
before speaking and and food and drink
is not to be consumed during meetings
water is permissible please use the
little shelves underneath your table
unfortunately you're going to see my
water bottle here because I don't have a
shelf so public hearings um I'm not
going to go through everything here you
can um study that on your
own um members of the public providing
inperson testimony please fill out pink
card cards and place them on the
clipboard located at the table where the
researcher is sitting before each
hearing the uh representative
kazinski will grab the appropriate
clipboard in pink cards and the
clipboard should be passed to the vice
chair members of the public shall not
approach the committee table for any
reason during while the hearing or yeah
executive session is in process and um
please follow the procedure for the pink
cards order of speakers providing
testimony that is the witnesses I will
allow Prime sponsors in introducing the
bill and or a co-sponsor introducing the
bill followed by co-sponsors of the bill
then senators and state reps then the
order would be state government
officials and following local officials
and members of the public I will do my
best to alternate between for and
against the bill very important if the
governor or chief justice enters the
room all members shall
rise upon their
entrance so um back to decorum
guidelines for members be always
respectful of members and speakers
please give your full attention to them
especially when they're
speaking ask questions of a witness
in order to clarify testimony and obtain
information please do not ever debate
the witness you will hear the
gavel personal opinions uh speeches
regarding bills other other things shall
not be prohibited during public
hearings save those types of things for
our executive session all questions for
speakers SL Witnesses shall be directed
to through the chair and then follow-up
questions by members of the committee
will be at the chair's discretion it is
my um aim to allow each member on the
committee who would like to ask a
question of a witness to be able to ask
at least one um and then a follow-up
question if you have additional
questions um I will s um cycle back to
you after other people have had a chance
to ask a first and follow-up
question and another thing that is
important to understand that when a
member of this committee is a prime
sponsor a co-sponsor of a bill or you
wish to provide testimony on a bill
that's before this
committee um you will leave your seat
here and and do so uh when I call you to
the witness stand and you may choose to
sit in the audience or you can come back
to your committee seat but you will not
be permitted to ask questions of
speakers providing testimony on that
bill now executive sessions
um normally additional public input will
not be permitted unless the chair
determines that any such input is
critical to the bill discussion and
debate and discussions during executive
session shall be confined to the bill
the bill under
consideration um I have the Motions that
um can be made during exec session
committee amendments um only a Committee
Member may offer an amendment during
executive session for a vote and
amendments may be drafted by any L
legislator but a member of this
committee must offer the amendment
please contact OS to request a draft
amendment to be drafted it's unofficial
OS will then send the final dra well
their final draft Amendment they'll work
with you um and once you are happy with
the
language my understanding is that that
Amendment the unapproved will be sent by
OLS to HCS located on the fourth floor
and they will automatically request 40
copies to be made for distribution at
the executive session it is the
responsibility of the member who will be
offering the amend amendment to go to
the fourth floor before the executive
session get those hard copy amendments
and then to um distribute them here and
also to place the uh extra copies on the
table for the
public um let's
see oh also um if you are going to offer
an amendment during an executive session
please email it to the entire committee
as soon as possible and members should
be attentive to their email so that they
can um check their email and look at the
amendment
before getting into the executive
session that's that's very
important um let's
see yeah and we would like any
amendments to be distributed to the
committee no later than 24 hours ahead
of the executive session
so then I have um some information with
regard to committee reports I won't go
through
own
and so with regards to committee
reports if you have been if you
volunteer or you are assigned to write a
committee report that may be a majority
or a Minority Report they shall be
submitted to both myself and the vice
chair representative McDonald for review
as soon as possible or no later than 48
hours following the executive session
this is important because I'm
responsible to review everything to make
sure that it is accurate and that it is
follow that it follows the proper
format and additionally after that the
uh committee reports go to the committee
researcher she has things that she needs
to look at that's part of her job and
then it goes to the speaker of the house
and he has the final
say so
um I need to pass in the bill file in
order that contains the committee report
and other paperwork in order for the
bills to appear in the house calendar so
that they can go to the house floor
notably house deadlines might require a
shorter submission timeline to to myself
in which case I will make every effort
to give you a heads up on that um we may
need to have same day submissions but I
will let you
know um I already went over that and
just to reiterate there there are some
handouts um with regards
to what a committee uh like a proper
well-written committee report should
look like and contain uh dis and and I
did give you some example reports that I
authored only because I had access to
those um on my
computer there are other um committee
reports that that you could use as a
model please um reference the um the
house calendars for that so um
one other thing that I would like to um
offer to this committee is what I call
guideline principles for Effective
committee meetings so I have four main
topics and I I will go through this
because I think this is important
reflection be mindful of personal
assumptions and biases be tolerant of
views which conflict with yours
communication express yourself with
Clarity and respect for both yourself
and others listening
actively listen with the intent to
understand be receptive to what others
say in consideration of the possibility
that they might have knowledge Andor
insights that you lack and lastly
evaluation consider carefully consider
all inputs and information before
arriving at a conclusion I I think that
if we can follow these guidelines in
this committee and with regards to um
the people's work that we have before us
we will do an excellent job and be
effective and um productive as a
committee so to wrap it up miscellaneous
um I've noted to please see house rules
45 as well as rules house rules 100
through1 um for more detailed
information with regards to committees
so um anticipated bills to this referred
to this committee it looks like we're
going to have quite a bit so um uh based
on the lsrs that were
requested it looks to me like we going
to potentially have 60 house bills the
last time I checked on Sunday we have 40
referred to this
committee and I'm
estimating maybe as many as that Senate
Bill LSR s have been requested they AR
aren't all going to come over to the
house but we're going to maybe have um a
fair amount but we deal with the Senate
bills after
crossover um okay so again for now house
uh our committee meetings will be our
regular committee day will be
Monday um I will always have
announcements at the beginning of our
meetings as well as at the end for
important dates to that that we need to
be um attentive to and just to reiterate
how sessions will normally be held on
Thursdays with the possibility of a
Wednesday and to conclude this
orientation I would ask that all
committee members kindly send me your
best contact information in an email and
I have it listed here um please provide
your the the best email that you
actually check it doesn't have to be
your legislative email as well as a
phone number and please indicate if you
would like that this will not be
published but if you would like that
information to be shared with our
committee only please so
note and um don't hesitate to contact me
with any questions or concerns at any
point I am here to serve this
so as I said um the
chair has improperly scheduled the
orientation we are now based on what
clock we look at 25 minutes behind
schedule so I'm going to allow the clerk
to get organized and then we will start
y
set bner right here
okay I don't have my gabble yet so I'm
going to have to use my water bottle
bottle so at this time I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 84 allowing
municipalities to collect fees for
certain recreational vehicles located on
Campground
properties so here with us today do yes
uh we have representative thocker from
Swansea who is here to introduce the
us welcome representative
vulner thank you madam chair and thank
you for inviting me to start off your
your session I don't know if being first
is an advantage or not but here we go uh
HB 84 is a bill that uh allows
municipalities to set a fixed fee
instead of collecting real estate
property taxes for from
unregistered recreational vehicles on
campgrounds
um the fee would be collected through
the
campground uh
owners uh right now the the uh law works
this way that each April 1st the
campground reports to the municipality
all of the RVs that are on site and
identifies those that are properly
registered with with a motor vehicle or
trailer
plates uh and those RVs are exempt from
Municipal property tax those that are
not
registered are there for the season if
they're there on on on April 1st uh the
municipality would then collect assess
and and collect uh real estate taxes
from those RVs that like a cabin or a
cottage on on U on on the campground
property um the problem is and this was
identified to me by my discussions with
the collector and assessing Department
in
Swansea that it takes hours and hours to
track down all these people a lot of
them are out of state
people uh they often find that the RV
has been sold there's no real process
for for stopping that sale or or
collecting taxes before the sale uh
there these you know it depends on the
state that they're from whether they
have a title or not
um it's um it it takes more time and
more effort for them to collect real
estate
taxes uh than than they actually realize
through the taxes so the idea here is to
is to have a a fixed fee a small fee uh
that would be collected in lie of real
estate taxes on these uh RVs that are
basically used as yearround seasonal uh
vacation
homes um again this is a request I
received from the to of Swansea we have
the the uh Town Administrator here to
answer more detailed questions but I'd
be happy to answer what I
can thank you representative fogner for
introducing the bill are there any
sponsor representative Dolan thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh what would the fees be uh
that are proposed to be collected so the
way this is set up is that the
municipality would have the option of
imposing a fee or they could continue to
collect real estate taxes if they set a
fee that that would be up to the select
of the
Town bill has a maximum of
$200 $200
annually um so but they could pick any
number up to that uh
typically these uh if you were to
register your your RV trailer for
example you would be paying a taxes to
wherever Town you're registered in it be
based upon the original sales price and
the depreciation you
know you know that that that fee
schedule set up by the state so $200
$100 is sort of in the uh often would be
they less than they would pay in in in
taxes to the
town uh but you know it's really it's a
matter of um if if they don't want to
pay that fee then they register their
vehicle RV as a
vehicle thank
you are there any other questions for
sponsor representative
stavis thank you madam chair um how did
you arrive at the fee
of not to exceed $200 was that something
that the assessors recommended based on
what they are trying to collect right
now or yes we discuss the value again
it's not so much at least from swansea's
point of view the it's not so much how
much they're collecting but how much
time they have to spend to collect it
because we're spending you know hours on
that um the $200 is is approximately
what you would pay
in real estate property taxes for a a uh
do my math
correctly a RV that might be a at
$8,000 because if it's if it's
registered then it's that's not exactly
how it works but uh again that brings in
point another problem is that the
assessors don't really have
a experience in how to Value
recreational vehicles I mean they're
they do buildings and
land so it's kind of a hit or miss
whether they they get that number
correctly but it would be what they
would pay if their RV were valued at
about $8,000 a typical $25 per thousand
Municipal
you next to speak to this bill is Jeremy
morning Madam chair welcome Mr Sprint
members of the municipal and County
government Committee just one
second please um for the record please
state your name who you represent and
whether your position on the bill
support or oppose or are neutral thank
you yep my name is Jeremy Sprint I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Campground Owners Association the
association opposes the amendment to uh
7270 or HBA
um I can
appreciate what uh appears to be the
intent behind this amendment to the RSA
um however its implications are
concerning as the executive director of
the a membership based Association that
represents over 100 private business
owners I manage significant day-to-day
operations along with Duce collections
production of an annual 100 page
publication en camping and recreational
vehicle show with close to 100
exhibitors in 7,000 to8 7 to 8,000
attendees annually I'm very familiar
with the challenges of chasing
money however this amendment as it's
written is complex and the language is
open to Broad
interpretation it's unclear whether the
proposed Municipal fee is intended to be
a supplement or replace existing taxes
the association was not consulted before
this amendment was in introduced
obviously hindering the opportunity to
have a thorough and informed discussion
which in turn ends up bringing us here
today um the origins of this RSA predate
the decade that I've been with the
association but um I can tell you
throughout that time it has been nothing
but a continuous confusion and conflict
I've had a number of conversations with
the Dr office uh discussing the issues
that it
creates I've encountered situations
ranging from towns attempting to place
leans on campsites uh which are property
taxes have already been paid by the
owners the town's trying to impose tax
liabilities on new seasonal campers for
previous campers uncollected
debts I've also seen towns attempting to
enforce r rsas that don't apply um I've
even seen notices to campers threatening
misdemeanor charges for moving campers
before approving tax payment I actually
have a permission to move mobile home
notice that was sent despite these being
recreational vehicles not mobile homes
um it's actually signed by the tax
collector ctor and the board of
selectman from the
town I can't even fathom to imagine the
liability issues that were involved if
the campground owner had been told uh to
prevent someone from leaving their
property before taxes are being
paid a number of Campground owners
indicated in conversations that these
municipalities find current system
burdensome and sometimes they don't even
want to deal with it I've actually read
minutes from a board of assessor meeting
revealing that the Town Administrator
States believing the administrative
effort to access assess these vehicles
outweighs the revenue generated yet they
have no alternative because of what it
states in the
RSA particularly problematic aspect of
this amendment um is an attempt to
unfairly place the burden of collecting
taxes and fees on Campground owners
they're not Tax Collectors this
amendment lacks Clarity regarding the
calculation of the proposed fee of up to
$200 and the criteria for which it's
based um this uncertainty is just
another extension of the inconsistent
application of recreational vehicles
that I see often I think you're seeing
evidence of this in another form with
what's going on in Rochester right now
where it sounds like they've recently
tried to Value recreational vehicle as
if it was a home furthermore this
amendment doesn't clarify who'll be
collecting fees from other land owners
across the state who have unregistered
RVs or trailers on their properties you
know one of the reasons why some of
these RVs are not registered is because
they are left there in storage at the
campgrounds are in the winter when
they're not open their permanent residen
is somewhere else they only they're
they're only here for the summer if
there was stored at another facility it
wouldn't even be subject to this
taxation the reality is that this is not
a revenue generator for mun towns and M
municipalities in most instan most
instances it seems they incur more time
effort and expense than the revenue that
it brings in I think if that wasn't the
case I don't think we'd be here today um
that being said I would propose the most
straightforward solution which is
completely remove recreational vehicles
as defined in RSA 216 I from this
section of the
law I appreciate you guys taking the
time today to hear me out thank you Mr
sprince you're welcome does anybody have
a question for Mr
Sprints seeing none thank you appreciate
branley welcome to Municipal and County
government state your name your position
and who you represent good morning my
name is Michael branley I'm Town
Administrator for the town of Swansea
and I am here in support of HB
84 um Swansea is home to three c three
campgrounds two of which allow
recreational vehicles to stay
unregistered in the campground year
round several years ago the Department
of Revenue Administration began
requiring municipalities to tax
unregistered RVs in campgrounds as real
estate Swansea complied with this
requirement however quickly realized
several flaws with the system first the
amount of tax revenue genate generated
comes nowhere near covering the costs to
develop the values collect the tax and
deal with the problems that the Bill's
cause taxing RVs requires the town's
assessor which for many communities
including Swansea is a contra is a
contractor paid hourly for their
services to inspect the campground
around April 1st the assessor inspects
the campgrounds for unregistered RVs and
develops an assessed value for them
based on their age make and model of the
60 RVs Swansea taxed in 2024 the average
tax bill was
$114 of that total almost a third of the
tax bill value and end up being abated
or waved so the town only collected
around
$4,700 of which about 25% stays with the
town or under
$1,200 this is like the loss of money on
dog licenses although at least those
have the purpose of rabies
prevention as has been mentioned by
other speakers taxing a mobile home a
mobile vehicle like an RV is not like
taxing a home or other real property in
ways that make it very challenging to
colle collect this tax if a land owner
does not pay their property taxes the
town will put a lean on the deed at the
registry of deeds and either collect
when the property sells or eventually
take ownership by tax deed with an RV
there is no deed to lean or mechanism to
take ownership or Force repayment this
creates the worst kind of tax where
conscientious people who pay the bill
they receive are punished and those who
do not do not pay it suffer no
consequence also unlike other real
estate RVs can also be registered as a
vehicle an RV that is registered is not
subject to property tax because property
is taxed as of April 1st which is not
exactly Peak camping season in New
Hampshire the registration stickers are
often not on the RVs when the town
inspects the tax bills in May then
prompt phone calls from irate RV owners
who received a tax bill even though
their RV was registered either because
it was not registered on April 1st or
the sticker was not yet on the vehicle
also because there is no deed ownership
information comes from the campgrounds
who have no incentive to provide
accurate information inaccurate billing
leads to needing to generate new bills
Andor
abatements HB 84 seeks to solve these
and other issues with the current system
by eliminating this unjust tax and
replacing it with a fee on the
campgrounds for unregistered RVs the fee
will be collectable by the municipality
from the campground where the current
tax is difficult to collect by
generating a flat amount per RV the time
and cost to develop individual
assessments based on the specific
details of of the RV is eliminated call
to the calls to the town from RV owners
disputing the tax saying their RV was
registered or sold uh and any number of
other issues will no longer happen I
think there's been discussion about
trying to develop another solution I
think we'd be supportive of that uh we
just wanted to start the discussion
about trying to collect an issue which
it sounds like is a problem for uh the
campground owners as
well thank you Mr branley other
questions for the speaker
representative Walker thank you madam
chair uh I'm from Rochester so it's
blowing up in my uh my community I just
had a quick question with your parks in
Swansea do you have campers that have
additions like enclosed porches adus
because that's what we have in Rochester
which qualifies for Real Estate so our
primary focus is on the RVs themselves
I'm not I don't want to speak to
improvements such as decks and
enclosures like that I'm not aware of
that part of the issue so much it's more
the RVs specifically for us well the
reason why I ask is
that those RVs are no longer mobile when
they're like that so I just wondering if
your assessor uh I guess you have a
contractor has noted that anywhere that
they're actually permanent structures
now not that I recall but I could get
back to the comme on that that's all as
a a reminder to new committee members
you are permitted to ask one question
and then you need to ask permission to
followup are there any other questions
seeing none thank you also if you have
some written testimony could you pass
that
along next we have Mr Richard
Sullivan for the rord state un
name who you represent and your position
on the bill thank
you my name is Richard
Sullivan I represent Harbor Hill
campground in Meredith New Hampshire and
I'm here to oppose this bill today
because I think it unfairly treats
campgrounds um as opposed to any other
property owner um back in 2013 is is
when the Department of Revenue sent out
notices to all the assessors that they
had to really clamp down on this new law
and and start enforcing
taxing uh RVs and other unregistered
trailers so I got this letter that said
they'll begin assessing trailers
throughout the town and this includes
travel trailers in campgrounds as well
as unregistered box trailers used as
storage so um fast forward 10 years
later so that that April in 2013 the
assessor came to my Campground
and I welcomed him showed him around and
I asked how are you going to attempt
to you know if you're going to treat if
you're going to tax me for my
unregistered trailers on my property how
are you going to go around the rest of
the town and capture all these other
structures and box trailers and all
these things um so that we're all being
treated fairly in the town you can't
just come straight after a campground
and he said over the 10 years assessors
go to properties um visit each property
every at least once every 10 years and
he said I'll capture them all then as I
go around I still felt that was unfair
because he comes to my Campground every
year but he he's only going to look at
everybody else's property every 10 years
so fast forward 10 years later they've
never taxed another trailer anywhere
else in the property anywhere else in
Meredith maybe that's not 100% true I I
but I can point to numerous um box
trailers throughout my town that are not
being taxed because I can see it all on
the assessing database so I feel like
we're being very unfairly targeted um by
this bill and by and by the previous one
but I by I understand the the the need
for the law the idea behind it so I'm
not 100% against the idea but the way
it's being enforced is unfairly
targeting
campgrounds um there's no other property
owners in any town that are being asked
to self
declare uh uh you know real EST low
value real estate lots of people have
sheds other trailers that technically
are called real estate there's no other
proposal that would that would tax these
structures to treat us all fairly so um
I appreciate your time that's that's all
I had to say I feel it's very unfair
Dees thank you uh Madam chairwoman and
the rest of the committee my name is
Brody Dees and I represent the Hampshire
Municipal Association we are a voluntary
Association made up of uh all the towns
in the state of New Hampshire um and we
advocate for their interest here in
conquered and on different bills and
proposals that come before your
committee and others um I testifying in
support of House Bill 84 um this was a
member request by the town of Swansea
and a few others to their local
legislature and they contacted us about
the issue that they are dealing with
which is um the cost to try to assess
all of these individual RVs that aren't
registered and with the timeline of when
they have to be assessing them um makes
it so then at times they're either
losing money or barely breaking even um
trying to uh collect this Revenue um
these are improvements that are made to
these properties if someone is for
example as the representative alluded to
earlier are making improvements to an RV
that they're essentially using similarly
to an fix structure um the goal isn't to
try to squeeze um campgrounds and to
make their lives more difficult the goal
is to make sure that towns are able to
collect the revenues that uh state law
um currently permits them to collect and
this is a way to make it more workable
for those towns um to make it more fair
um when they're trying to collect this
Revenue so um I think with that there's
been a lot of great points that were
brought up by the town of Swansea in the
issues that towns are dealing with when
trying to assess and collect this tax
revenue and um hopefully this will be a
way where uh campgrounds can essentially
collect the fee from these people who
don't register their RVs and then can
include that in their property tax bills
as a way to streamline the um the
assessing and the collecting process for
these communities uh with that I will um
take any questions that the committee
members have thank you Mr dases any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so the final p pink card that I have
here on House Bill 84 is
for Mr Dave and I don't can't make out
that last
name could you repeat that when when you
sit
down also I think that you've indicated
that you would like 10 minutes to speak
that was oh yeah um some of what I've
said has already been said perfect so
don't repeat that just add new new
information and try to keep it um 3
minutes or less thanks uh it looks the
first read of that bills uh clearly uh I
don't have it in front of me but it it
seems the witness to spend for could you
please for the record state your name
where you're from and who you represent
in your position uh Dave bankus I'm from
wolfb
and I'm the treasurer of the New
Hampshire Campground
Association I've also owned a campground
in my family for 55
years and we have quite a bit of
this when I first skimmed over the bill
I said great my wife is doing all the
assessor work chasing down registrations
and things like that and presents a
package to the town every April 1st and
I said she's going to get 200 bucks for
her work and then I read it again and
realized that it was
charging an additional
$200 so I'm still a little confused
because the sponsor of the bill clearly
said this morning and in an email to our
association that this $200 was instead
of Taxation which I have different
feelings about uh 25 years ago 30 years
ago we used to measure the trailers and
if they were under 320 square feet they
were considered
untaxable and it was pretty clean and
simple this
taxing things with wheels as real estate
is very
problematic and uh it just is difficult
to work so you're dealing with something
that'll never work in the first place uh
we've had
we've had trailers that have left with
no forwarding address and a lean was put
on our
campsite so that the next person that
occupied it got a tax bill for previous
occupants that they never even knew so
what do you do in that situation if
you're a campground owner and you have
two sites and one has a lean on it and
the tax bill is going to fall on anyone
who occupies that site you pay the bill
so the law says we're not liable for it
but in all practicality we have paid the
bills other than that uh it's very
unfair in the fact that it applies to
campgrounds but it's inexpedient to make
it apply to everyone in the town not 50
ft from my property line my neighbor has
a box trailer and a motor home that have
been sitting there for at least 20 years
and through many evaluations when I
checked last Friday they were not
taxed so the tax is inequitable in the
fact that if you park something outside
of a campground it's just too hard to
find it too hard to appraise it and too
hard to tax it the gentleman sponsor of
this bill looks like he's trying to
attach that problem he's trying to make
it easier for me to play a fat a flat
fee
tax but it still doesn't address the
inequality of the fact that if you are
part somewhere in the town they will
never find your RV and they will never
tax it the unit 50 ft from my property
is a box trailer which I think is
exactly what this started with in
Atkinson when the judge said you have to
tax the box
trailers so anyway I'm not I put down
that I was not in favor of this because
I was in the impression that it was an
addition to
tax I still am a little confused but I'm
under the impression this morning that
this is in lie of it
attacks which I think I could I think I
could work with that because it it would
simplify things a little bit like it was
years
ago and my wife will have less
work it would the tax the if they Town
charged $200 my wife would be paying
over
$122,000 to the
town in addition to the tax but if it
was instead of the tax I I don't know I
think maybe there's some hope
here
question thank you sir
questions I I had one with regards to
the the the the the box container in a
uh camper that you referenced parked I
think you said in your neighborhood or
whatnot are do people reside no no it's
it's um the original court case had to
do with box Trail that were used for
storage my neighbor has a box trailer
used for storage and it's never been
taxed right up until last Friday when I
checked they also have an RV motor home
parked in their property but the problem
is the tax department goes for the low
hanging fruit so they go to the T
campgrounds because it's like harvesting
a cluster of grapes with one
snip my wife does all the work but to go
all over town and try to search out
every trailer every RV is like every tax
assessor I've talked to says that's just
not cost effective thank you thank you
any other questions seeing
none uh is there anybody else in the
room who would like to speak to this
bill who hasn't had the opportunity to
do
fauler um
you could email your clarification to
the committee thank you so um with that
I'm going to close the hearing on House
Bill
so um we are behind schedule and at this
time I am going to open the public
hearing on House Bill 86 FN local
increasing the cost of service for
notice of civil forfeiture of unlicensed
dogs to the rate for certified mail and
we have with us this morning
representative St Clair who is the Prime
sponsor to introduce the bill to the
committee welcome representative St
Clair
and it is indeed a pleasure to be here
thank you
um this is I hate to say this but this
is really to me a common sense
um answer to a a situation we have in
lonia and apparently
Statewide where postage rates have gone
up and the cost of mailing out
notices to people who have not
registered their dogs has not gone up to
meet that
therefore my constituents in District 5
lonia are subsidizing no matter how
small the amount may be or large the
amount may be the postage to people who
have not done their duty to register
their
dogs and that that's really
the pretty clear description of of what
we're trying to do here with this
bill and my city clerk uh is here to uh
give you the any real details that need
to be clarified for this that thank you
for that bill introduction
representative are questions for the
prime
again next to speak on House Bill 86 I
Gargano so it looks like you've
indicated four minutes um if
possible please take three or
less I had to Charlie told me to change
it to
four uh good morning Madam chairperson
and committee members my name is Katie
Gargano I'm the city clerk in lonia and
I contacted representative St Clair
about the submission of of this bill
when following the Civil forfeiture
process we must send notices by
certified mail or they must be hand
delivered in the city of lonia we share
an animal control officer with two other
communities and when we saw this past
year we had 300 notices to send the best
option was for us to mail
them I feel like the requested language
is uh the language change is simple over
the years we're continuously seeing
rates increase by the United States
Postal Service and I'm trying to cover
the municipality's expenses for sending
out the notices as required by law the
City of Laconia licenses approximately
2,800 dogs per year generating money for
the Department of Agriculture and the
City of
Laconia in 2024 we had to send 300 civil
forfeitures which were a cost of
$964 per letter but the current RSA
allows for us to collect seven so we
that's thank you other questions for the
speaker representative Walker thank you
madam chair uh how much time does your
office take to process all these civil
forfeitures every
year well we have software that takes
care of understand tracking so it
probably takes
us a day to prepare the list and we
print out the Civil forfeitures um the
certified mail cards come right out out
of our printer and then we just put them
on the envelopes and send them out so it
probably takes about a
day as a reminder to committee members
this is not a conversation with the
witness you are permitted to ask one
question and then if you want to say
anything additional please indicate that
you would like to ask a follow-up
question other any other
questions for Ms
you next I have M Tina
bill my name is Tina Guilford I'm the
town clerk in
Derry um we have a very similar problem
to what Laconia has um we license over
7,000 dogs in Dairy and while we do have
an animal control officer um in 2023 we
had
1,821 uh unlicensed dogs um in
1,244 unlicensed dogs so we are working
on getting our residents to license um
however this is quite a bit of money
that is being subsidized by other Dairy
residents with the cost of the Civil
forfeiture because it would be
impossible by the statutes um for my
Animal control officer to go to all
these doors and post notices by the
deadline in
statute um it does take my office um
about 3 4 days to get all the Civil
letters
out um was like I said 1,200 of them
this year and um is quite a bit of money
subsidizing by by the
taxpayers um all other required um
notices that we are required to send by
certified mail for example tax leans
nsfs all those things they all have
current cost of postage
um so this seems like it's uh something
relatively simple because if they
license their dog on time nobody needs
to pay this so this is only for people
who do not license and they should be
the people paying the
freight and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you Miss Guilford
questions for the
next I have Tammy is it
bakey thank you welcome to Municipal and
County government uh you have indicated
five minutes just perfect thank you good
morning members I am Tammy bakey I am
the town clerk tax collector of the
wonderful town of Kingston I am here
representing the New Hampshire City and
town clerks Association the association
and I fully support
hb86 currently the clerks can only
recoup $7 from the
$8.95 Cent cost to male civil fores
notice is as required by RSA
46614 Kingston has approximately 1,800
dogs last year we
sent 145 civil forture letters which
cost the town
$282 in small towns like Kingston This
has an impact on our budget I respect ly
ask for your support in amending RSA
46614 thank you Miss bakey that was
efficient questions for the
witness seeing none thank
you and the last pink card that I have
Healey hi uh Dan Healey Nash city clerk
um and I support this bill uh so as some
of the other clerks that already
mentioned um the the cost of postage is
exceeds the amount that we're able to
charge in Nasha we have about
10,500 dogs to license each year and I
believe last year we had about 2,000
that required the Civil forfeiture um
even after you know trying to get people
to come in by email reminders and all
that so it ends up costing uh the city
quite a bit of money uh if we were to
all of the Civil forfeitures at that uh
current rate so I think uh it's a pretty
straightforward bill I think uh the
speakers prior uh all hit on the points
that uh we had um I've talked to other
clerks and I haven't found a single
clerk that disagrees with this bill it's
it was sent out to our association and
and we only had uh positive feedback for
it so you open to any questions thank
you Mr Healey questions for Mr
hle seeing none thank you
thanks so that was the last pink card
that I had is there anybody present in
the room who wishes to speak to this
bill who has not had the opportunity to
do
so seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing
next on our agenda today we have House
Bill 92 I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill 92 that's an act prohibiting
an individual from SIM
simultaneously serving on the local
zoning board and planning board and with
us this morning we have representative
Joe Alexander who is the Prime sponsor
of this
legislation well thank you madam chair
members of M fman County for the record
my name is representative Joe Alexander
I'm I serve the town of goof toown um I
filed this bill um to address a
perceived conflict of interest that
could arise on the or not conflict of
interest but separation of powers
argument that could arise on the local
level um it's a bipartisan bill it's on
behalf of one of my constituents
actually um to address a perceived
separation of powers under the current
law and some municipalities one can run
for Planning and Zoning Board and serve
at the same time um My Hope Is that
members of the committee can see where
this can be a conflict I believe when a
member of the public appeals a local
decision of the planning board to the
zoning board they should be able to
appeal it to an entirely new committee
made up of new officials and I had OS do
some research and um to my surprise the
last time this bill was filed was 1993
so I was not alive at the time
um HB 299 L um in 1993 was recommended
itl U because the committee felt there
was already a mechanism on the local
level to address the issue um although
some towns or some municipalities um
this is still possible so I think that
Statewide we should make it a policy
that if you're going to run for one of
the boards you serve on one board and
not the other um I believe we need a
Statewide approach this law we
consistently know each M municipality um
has separation of powers member can rest
assured that their appeal of a planning
board decision will be conducted fairly
and impartially um with new membership
so I hope you'll look favorably on this
committee U my constituent is here to
testify as well but I'm happy to answer
questions but I I think this pretty
straightforward famous last words I
think people say that a lot so thank you
representative Alexander questions for
the prime
sponsor representative
Dolan thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my my question
the uh your comments seem to indicate
that this would apply only to planning
board and Zoning Board elected positions
what about those communities where those
positions are not elected that they're
appointed what's the intersection in
that in that uh
situation um this would apply to it says
any pointed or elected members it would
apply to both in the law the Bas based
on how the bill is written thank you yep
additional questions representative
frock thank you madam chair thank you
representative in your
opinion would
requiring recusal from a hearing on the
second board serve the same
purpose um I think it could and and this
is in the committee's hand to make that
decision um I think there's already me
there's already parts of the RSA where
members can't serve on two boards so for
instance I serve on the gtown budget
committee as well I would not be allowed
to serve on the budget committee and the
select board unless I was the select
board appointee to the budget committee
so there's already mechanisms in the RSA
to address some of these perceived like
um separation of powers arguments so um
we can be consistent and do the Planning
and Zoning Board because they're they
conflict with each other or um we can do
what you suggest but I think this is
particularly valid as
well thank you for your response you're
representative
Elward thank you madam chairman thank
you for taking my question I'm
confused the um sentence
preceding uh the amendment starting on
line
8 it I believe it is
saying that you can serve on a planning
board
board and a local land use board is
defined in RSA 672 colon
7 so when you go to the
definition planning board and zoning
board so am I you know my dyslexia
getting to me but is it not conflicting
with the amended language thank you I I
well thank you for the question
representative I don't think it is
because it's saying any two appointed or
elected members of a board so planning
board cannot Also Serve together on
another board um they also address the
conflict of the conflict on um
Conservation Commission as well so I
don't I think it's pretty clear in that
language
but I that's what I got for you okay
thank you y additional
questions I have one go ahead for
clarification um let me just back up so
when when a bill is before this
committee and we have a hearing members
we we are to focus on the the bolded
italicized language because that's the
change that's being made we um typically
don't concern ourselves with the other
language that appears printed in in the
bill but I do understand that
representative Elward this is a little
bit of a gray area so my question would
be um with regards to the lines that she
indicated there's the local land use
board um perhaps if you could
clarify what are local land use boards
could you name them and and list them um
from what I know there's three there's
planning board zoning board and
conservation commissions so um I I mean
again this is part of the bill so this
is Madame chairwoman this bill is in
your hands so um if you'd like to
address other parts of the RSA um feel
free but I think you understand what the
intent of me sponsoring this bill was so
hopefully we'll keep that as
questions representative um Gilman thank
you madam chair um my question having
served on on a zoning board um is do you
see this affecting the towns and like
mine that have trouble um we don't have
an elected um planning board or zoning
board do you see they're being trouble
attracting um volunteers to fit the
empty spots and that this is one way to
help us fill those spots um thank you
for the question representative I think
it's an important point to make and I
think I think you're right that are
sometimes Town boards that struggle to
find memberships they have appointed
mechanism they have a mechanism to
appoint members in those cases but I
also really think that although there
may be trouble the separation of powers
argument is more important than the
trouble they're going to find maybe with
a member or something um I think that
part of the reason why we're in the
housing crisis we are in right now is
that we'll have members of One board and
then another board and maybe there's a
rejection to an application planning
board appeal it to the zoning board and
they see the same faces so I just I I
think that
the the conflict is more important than
maybe finding the membership because
there are mechanisms to appoint members
of the public in those cases thank you
follow up Madam
chair yes thank you uh so to further
that out U most of the land use com uh
boards and you forgot the HDC and the
Heritage commission um which um have a
select board representative on them or
uh like the HDC has a Heritage
commission member vice versa and it's a
cross-pollination kind of thing do do
you see that it may help a zoning board
to have a planning board member to um
explain how they came to their decision
or vice versa I the bill is in your
hands um I think you understand what my
intent with it is um
I that's a good point that we have
select board members on the budget
committee and their voting members and
and so if there's a planning board
representative or something like that
that's completely valid whether you want
to make that member a voting member or
not that's entirely up to you but um
that's a good point Thank
questions representative
Elward thank you madam chairman my
question is if this law goes into effect
as
written what happens to the board
members that are serving on both boards
do they automatically
resign what if there's no Quorum left
have you thought about the ramifications
of that um I have and I I think that in
cases where there's changes to Municipal
law um there's associations that inform
um different communities of the changes
so Municipal Association I'm sure will
testify on this um if this La law would
go into effect they would notify the
towns and the towns would deal with that
accordingly um again there's appointed
members of boards that can fill
vacancies of elected officials until the
next town election comes up and then we
can elect a new new person to fulfill
the rest of that term that's how I see
it um playing out you're
welcome any further questions seeing
so um I have one final pink card from Mr
Phil J jro you have indicated five
minutes and I would kindly ask if you
could um do it in three or less and if
you have something written or you have
more to say feel free to email that to
RS yeah about the recusal I found that
does not happen I approached the town to
put some signs up and they said no I
could not put two signs up because the
ordinance says I'm only allowed one sign
and I said this is political sign this
is to petition the government I was
basically wanting to protest against a
project the zoning board gave permission
to next to my property and I hear a
247 buzzing and humming from this
project for two and a half
years okay so now they're concerned that
my putting two signs up is going to
devaluate other people's property when
my property is being devaluated but they
see no problem with that the witness
shall suspend um Mr juru it's it's not
clear to me that your testimony is
relative to the changes in the bill this
is some background information with
regards to town politics I ask that you
focus okay your comments
to if you support the proposed amendment
to this RSA through this Bill thank you
okay well my point was basically the
chairman of the uh zoning board who sits
on the planning board see saw nothing
wrong with the rec cruising themselves
they saw no conflict of interest even
though they were involved with the
planning board when the sign ordinances
were being amended and enacted now I
brought this to court and the judge saw
nothing wrong with this and he didn't
even you know I mean that's kind of
bizarre
because here you have a planning board
defending their own zoning board now
this comes basically to your question
about the
um let me see how that
here was it about um finding volunteers
um repres
presentation let me go I'll stop back
that basically the chairman of the
joning board I got this one
here and the um on the planning board
the judge saw nothing wrong with that
and this is a an ordinance that they're
involved with enacting so basically this
is kind of like a judge being involved
with the enact
of the
legislation and then going around and
making a ruling on the legislation they
were involved with that's what this
comes down to this is the separation of
power I mean how can you be a judge
because if you look at the
ordinances or the statutes for why a
zoning board is defined or why it's
enacted it's the it's for constitutional
protection for the people at the Town
level so the zoning board can hear these
complaints address these complaints on
the local level without having to go to
the state level first but now in this
case here you're going and you're saying
okay well now I'm facing the person that
passed the law and was all for this law
and he's the judge well the person is
the judge not necessarily he because it
was a she and how are you going to
defend yourself against
that I mean it's it's ridiculous and
this is what happened I can I mean in my
test I don't have the 20 here I think it
was 20 of you my printer uh started
fading out but I can pass it out some
but I mean your zoning board is
basically established to listen to
complaints on zoning ordinances that's
what your statute says you can't enact a
zoning ordinance without first
establishing a zoning board so how are
you sitting there passing these laws are
involved with the writing of the laws
while you're also interp ing these laws
and that's the whole point to this thing
it's just common sense to separate the
powers because this is what happened
already and the judge saw nothing wrong
with it the you know the the personing
on the zoning board saw nothing wrong
with it who's to Define what a conflict
of interest is and in this state
basically a conflict of interest means
if there's money involved okay and not
necessarily when our rights are being
taken away and deprived that also can be
a conflict of interest and that's a user
of power basically
thank you Mr jeru I'll any questions
questions for Mr
giru seeing none I appreciate you taking
the time to provide your testimony and
yes so like I said that was the last
card is there anybody present in the
room who wishes to speak on this bill
101 okay okay okay so seeing that I have
no other pin cards I'm going to close
so thank you for your patience this
chair has um not predicted the length of
bills very well so we are a little bit
behind here but I would like to um hold
the hearing on House Bill 99 here before
we take a lunch break I have three pink
cards and I will ask that um people
who speak to this bill would limit their
comments to 3 minutes or less so at this
time I would like to open the hearing on
House Bill 99 relative to a waiver from
property taxes for disable veterans and
I see that I have representative Mafi
here who is the Prime sponsor of the
bill to introduce this legislation to
the committee welcome to Municipal and
County government thank you madam chair
great to be here really seriously it is
great to be here and and thanks for
taking this up for the record my name is
Mike Moffett uh representing marac
District 4 in the beautiful towns of
londondary not London Lowden and
Canterbury Lowden and Canterbury I
submitted this measure at the request of
a veteran a couple veterans actually and
as you know I chair the house committee
on state federal relations the the
veterans committee and I try to make we
try to make veterans issues and requests
uh get to the appropriate attention in
various venues and platforms and
committees so uh
hb99 uh is about as succinct as you'll
ever see as you can see it's very short
it changes the relevant line in irsa 72
colon
27 to make the highend of a potential
disabled veterans uh tax credit to be
100% of the local property tax as
opposed to $700 which is what it is now
in
statute now I I must say am very aware
as you are the tax credit measures can
be a little bit tricky uh in the sense
that we all know
municipalities uh need to raise revenues
obviously and
they need these revenues to run
everything that they need to run so
Revenue shortfalls can be created by tax
credits for some um and and you all know
that so it's important to point out that
this is enabling
legislation uh it involves no
mandates should it move forward uh it
could be adopted by municipality should
this move forward it could be adopted or
utilized by a municipality or not it's
the nature of enable enabling
legislation um for example say the good
folks in any Town New Hampshire know
that their neighbor Mr Jones who is
totally disabled due to injury suffered
in Afghanistan simply can't afford to
pay his property taxes and will have to
give up his home and and leave leave any
town uh for some other living
Arrangement so the local officials
should this pass the local officials in
any town would have the option of giving
Mr Jones a break so he can stay in his
home and in the any town
community uh that's the essence of this
proposal so the question will arise as
to documenting what quote service
connected total disability unquote means
what what it entails and the easy answer
would be that it in involves producing
official VA certification to medical
certification to confirm such a status
of 100% disability service related
disability uh much the same way that a
DD214 document confirms a veteran status
for veterans seeking consideration for
for existing local property tax credit
options many many communities in the
State uh do this already for veterans uh
some to to a limit some do more than
others and it's up to the community if
they want to offer the uh tax credit
option now for veterans the veteran
simply needs to document his status via
that document the
DD214 so there are a lot of issues
surrounding aspects relating to 100%
disability status in terms of employment
grants dependence and on and on but I
don't know that those other issues
necessarily relate to this very simple
Bill and this this very tiny change or
enhancement to the existing
statute uh representative sudder is here
and he and I spoke about his concerns
that this measure could impact the
status of certain grants for Home
Improvements for totally disabled
veterans I'm not sure how well founded
his concerns are we've we've discussed
those uh in representative sud here and
he can speak briefly to those to that
possible aspect later his concern that
100% um tax credit could impact other
things uh and you all are the duty
experts on this I'm sure you'll um work
through that uh again my sense is his
concerns may be unfounded given the
simple intent of this measure but again
as I just said uh you not Al the bill
and and are the uh as we say in the the
Marine Corps the duty experts in this in
this field so again thank you for all
you do that's the bill and I'd be happy
to try to answer any questions if if
there are any thank you representative
Moffett questions for the prime sponsor
representative Walker thank you madam
chair I'm a little confused here if a
town so chooses to en enact this
legislation your thing do they act say
they wanted to do the 100% so they act
we're going to do the 100% is that
individually or all of them so in other
words if Mr Jones comes up and asks
specifically for that does the town have
to
vote on that or is it automatically a
blanket for all that thank you repres
it's a great question it's one that I've
pondered and thought about and and the
answer is uh if this enabling
legislation were to pass through uh I
would like to see the communities that
uh decide to uh adopt it have some
mechanism to address the situation you
described um and I'm not entirely clear
on If This Were to move forward if it
would be a
blanket uh adoption as you said and and
the reason that I've thought about this
and and and it's a great question is
there are
some uh veteran circumstances that are
more compelling than others I gave the
example of Mr Jones in any town which I
think is a a compelling example uh any
town by the way is a smaller Community
but say nashal manchest not everybody
knows everybody in in those
municipalities and they in evitably is a
spectrum and there may be some totally
dis dis uh disabled veterans whose
circumstances are not so dire and people
in the community know that so as to
whether the
community in the in the municipal
officials within the community would
have some discretion to uh focus on a
compelling disabled veteran as opposed
to someone who's not as compelling I'm
not sure that answer great question and
um I uh hopefully uh you'll figure it
out that that is a great question and
and it's one that concerns me as
well thank you representative the answer
to the question is that if this were to
become law and it's changed it would be
um appear on the warrant at the town and
the legislative body would would vote
upon it and therefore if it passed it
would apply to all uh veterans who
qualify under the language of this
section of
Statute the the town would not be voting
on individual
veterans I see representative Dolan has
a question thank you madam chair uh
representative MAF thank you for taking
my question um as I read this
change it gives the
community U the option of
voting to increase the
amount as it says in the legislation
from
$700 up to 100% so up to it could be 80%
or could be 90% it doesn't have to be
blanket 100% across the community it can
be whatever the community decides it can
afford when you when you're doing these
types of tax credits you take $100 from
one person that has to be made up by
$100 from the other person so the
community can do an a financial analysis
and says that this year we can afford to
go to 80% or this year we can afford to
go to 90% so it doesn't automatically be
100% is that am I reading that right
thank you for the question rep do that
is another great question and that issue
has come up as to uh discretion in terms
of if this was were to move forward
would the municipality if they adopted
it have discretion in terms of the
situation you just described did they
have to go to uh uh 100% of the tax
value as opposed to the 700 limit that
is there now um in putting this in there
was a suggestion that rather than have
100% which can varies right now the $700
or the $500 is consistent across the
board for every veteran now when you go
to 100% which is what this measure
proposes 100% for Mr Jones could involve
a $6,000 tax credit 100% from Mr Smith
could involve a $10,000 uh tax credit is
is is as you know that prop properties
are have different uh valuations so
that's a great question uh maybe Madame
chair has answered to this one too uh
but that that's a fair question when
we've thought about and um I'm not sure
exactly what the answer is or if now
that the committee has this bill if if
the the measure might be amended to uh
address the situation you just
described further questions for the
Primes spond representative
Colby thank you for coming today um how
would this change for uh RSA
7235 affect the veterans exemption in
RSA
7236 for a certain disabled veterans
what is what would be the difference
thank you for the question um I don't
have that RSA in front of me that's a
different line of the same uh RSA 72 too
um and I honestly right off top of my
head I don't want to try to answer that
definitively because I I'm not really
sure but I'm sure the answer could could
readily does anybody else have question
representative
France hi thank you um does that mean
the town would adopt a certain
percentage if they say for instance they
wanted to give you a 70%
would that be blanket for any totally
disabled ban it would be 70% of their
tax
bill thank you for the question
representative if I heard you correctly
you asking about a gradation of sorts
like if if someone's 70% disabled and
the answer is this is very specific uh
to 100% so representative Moffet that
that was not her question I'm going to
allow her to clarify her question so you
can answer it thank you you might want
to get a little closer okay um the town
needs to adopt this policy um the my
hearing eight is at the VA I'm
policy um so the town needs to adopt a
policy they e they go from anywhere from
$71 up to 100% of the uh person's tax
bill can they does the town could the
does the town adopt like say they decide
on
70% of the tax bill would that be
blanket that would just be their policy
that uh I oh thank you I think I
understand what your question is so you
wondering if the town might have
discretion to uh not go to 100% but go
to a different percentage or a fixed
cost I I touched on that a little bit
earlier about the notion of a fixed a
fixed amount as opposed to the 100%
which varies uh that's a great question
and as to whether the municipality would
have the discretion if this passes to uh
opt for something less than
100% um great question and I'm not clear
on if the municipality would have
discretion to uh to go less than 100% or
to a fixed amount that that's a a great
question and and I'm not clear at this
moment on what the answer would be but
I'm again like the other question I'm
sure it's readily
accessible that
answer additional questions I see
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and my
apologies if you don't know the answer
to this question but as I'm reading
current law there are a whole lot of
other conditions that have to be met
underneath what's out in your bill uh I
am assuming that when OS put this bill
into its draft form that they they
assumed that those current conditions
still have to be met I guess I just want
to make sure that I ask you that
question sure thank you for the question
and so there are in existing statute the
opportunity the option to for
municipalities to Grant a tax credit to
Veterans is predicated on certain
conditions I think that's what you're
referring to and this measure before you
is very short and uh the answer is uh
my understanding when OS drafted this
that they didn't see a need to restate
all the different um conditions for the
eligibility for the tax credit so that
interpretation
okay representative ma majori thank you
madam chair um I actually have two
questions and I have one for you madam
chair also but it's it's going to be the
same one for the sponsor thank you so
much for testifying have you contacted
or were the the ass was the assessing
Association contacted about this bill
and are they here to testify that's my
question uh thank you for your question
I did not uh contact that that or
organization as to whether the
researchers OSS may have I I do not know
okay thank
you and M followup for you madam do we
know if they're here because I I if
they're did they send in a pin card
the I do not have a pink card for them
you any further
so based on the bill language if a
municipality or actually a town were to
adopt 100% of the property
tax okay my question given that my
question is why do you could you
explain why you think or feel that this
is needed in addition to the RSA that
representative Colby cited which is um
72 36a which already does provide 100%
exemption for certain disabled veterans
specifically those who qualify under the
Sha or S homes why would we need this
provision in addition to that thank you
for the question Madam chair uh yes
there does seem to be a redundancy in in
this brief measure as compared to the
one you just described and my
understanding is that somehow there was
a gap that was seen in certain
circumstances that was not
covered uh and as to whether that Gap uh
really exists or is significant uh I'm
sure someone following me may be able to
speak to that or subsequently in the in
all the time that the committee will
have this this measure during the rest
of the month before you execute uh I'm
sure an easy answer can be uh attained
but I my understanding is that there was
some Gap under some some circumstances
with existing code or or statute that
this would uh uh make cover and make
sure there were no
gaps thank you and I have one final
question question
um the bill this is not the amended
language but the the section of Statute
refers to total disability is it true
that um a veteran could be totally
disabled but still
work and and and perhaps for example
maybe be the president of
bae thank you for that question lots of
great questions and that's another one
um the honble Lyn blanken Beaker who
some of you know uh uh former member of
this body uh very uh well respected uh
Navy captain in the reserves contacted
me on Saturday with regard to this and
uh to your point she specifically spoke
to me about some of the confusion about
what 100% disabled means totally
disabled means um and there is that's a
very potentially uh complicated and even
an emotional question because there are
uh Lynn The Honorable Lynn Blankenbaker
pointed out to me that there are many
veterans who are totally disabled have
100% disability who can still work and
so you all or many of you probably know
people who have percentage of disability
maybe even or 100% disabled and you see
them doing this doing that or working
and so the question arises um why is
somebody somebody who is ostensibly 100%
disabled uh doing this activity or why
are they working if they're 100%
disabled and or in some cases seeking a
tax credit and uh lind's point and I
won't get into it here uh in detail
other than to say she's concerned that
people understand that some veterans who
uh have PTSD related type disabilities
or physical disabilities need and should
work and even though they are 100%
disabled uh medically for whatever
combination of reasons um she thinks
that it's very important that they do
when when they can where they can uh be
gainfully employed uh or doing something
so if if that touches on your your
question I know and I know you know uh I
know your your husband is is uh has some
wonderful marine marine military
background so to your point uh it's a
tricky question and and it it there
needs to be some discussion
understanding on what 100% total
disability means and that it does not
preclude and should not preclude working
so somebody who's working may ask for
this tax credit if it goes forward and
um people need to understand that you
can work and still be
disabled thank you any further
questions representative Gilman thank
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative I think I want to follow
up on the uh chairwoman's question about
the two rsas which may or may not be in
Conflict
um is this supposed to fill the whole
where um RSA
7236 deals with the special home
adaptations and this bill does not thank
you for the question uh that goes right
to representative sudor is he still here
uh yes he is uh that goes right to his
question and concern and uh he's here
and I know he's going to speak to that
um in in detail and yes I I this was
initially a I was asked to try to move
this to you so you could look at this
tax credit option and as I mentioned
before there was a perceived Gap that
this may cover and the point you just
raised uh I'll I'll defer to
representative sudor because I know that
that's the piece of it that he
specifically wants to
address that sounds perfect any other
questions seeing none thank you for
introducing the bill to this committee I
appreciate it thank you madam
chair so um perfect segue uh next I have
a pink card for representative John
sudor so um you've asked to speak five
minutes I would kindly ask that you try
to keep your remarks to three minutes or
less if you have anything additional to
to share we we're way over schedule um
feel free to send that along to all the
committee members via email thanks thank
you madam chair thanks for giving me the
opportunity to address this this is
something I've kind of made a personal
expertise in the last decade about
helping veterans out and understanding
what the rules of law are and what
benefits veterans truly have here
there's nothing more disappointing than
going to a shop seeing a fellow Marine
that's lost his legs he's I got 30%
disability because that's what the
Marine Corps gave me he didn't even know
he had to go to the ba true story right
here in New Hampshire so I made it my
goal to go over this to answer some of
the questions that were asked earlier I
am also selected for my town to town of
Mason We address each request for VA
exemption individually not as a blanket
because each case is different each
individual is different uh so we can't
just do a blanket we don't haven't figed
figure out how we could just blanket it
we do it individual person by
request when it comes to RSA 7236 a the
question was asked about
the um s and sha well sah if I don't get
them backwards is meant to help
facilitate the building of a dwelling
for those veteran who has special needs
uh to live in the the other one is to do
special adaption to that same dwelling
or to a house they already own but what
we miss is that at the Veterans Hospital
right here in Manchester you can request
an evaluation of your house due to
orthop through the uh Prosthetics Clinic
they will send a representative out to
your house they will make changes
whatever you need including building
ramps making bathrooms kitchens designs
anything you need exact like that and we
can do it right here at the VA Hospital
a lot of veterans don't realize they can
do that after they make their evaluation
they'll send a contractor out and the
contractor will make the changes to your
house so I'm trying to bring that
awareness so when we tie these to just s
or
sha we're not doing a service we're
we're we're telling veterans you can't
even apply for this unless you have
these grants well that's not true
because the VA does it exactly the same
way and we need work on that language
that just because you own a house that's
Ada equip uh Ada equipped and the VA
comes out and make and makes the changes
to your house exactly the same thing is
going to happen in sah or
Si you can't apply for this loan I don't
think that was the spirit of 35 or 72
36a now how we determine what a
permanent disab dis disabled veteran is
is very simple the VA determines it for
us and we go off of their
recommendations when they send out a
letter of to about a veteran they talk
about his disability service connection
everything else about it what its
percentage is it will say things like
this service connected disability yes or
no your combined service connected
evaluation is whatever that percentage
is it says your currently monthly award
whatever that award is that's your VA
pay are you entitled to H uh hire level
of disability to be
unemployable it's either yes or
no that right there tells you that the
veteran is unemployable due to their
injuries is a yes or no answer are you
considered totally imp permanately
disabled due to your service connected
disabilities again yes or no so all this
is information that the veteran can
bring with them when they apply to their
local government to their local
Selectmen and it answers all the
when it comes to the 25 uh or 7236
a I submitted uh a paper in on it that
says it talks
about special adapted housing that they
must have these
grants well I submitted that after you
say that we should say or owns a house
that is ADA Compliant and meets the
needs for their disabilities or is
modified through the VA syst system the
the witness suspend we we need to we
need you to um restrict your comments to
the section of Statute that's in the
Bill yes ma'am Ma and not to speak to
another section of Statute that's not in
front of us and also you're at four
minutes so if you could um okay wrap it
up that would be great I'm kind of
passionate about this because I've
talked like I said with the director
William uh I'm going to murder his name
cadro he is the director of New
Hampshire Department of Veterans Affairs
and he's under impression and has
U of this is if a veteran doesn't have
either one of those grants they are not
allowed to even
apply they can have no legs no arms no
sight they can't apply because they
don't have those
grants and I don't think that was the
intent at all so I support this 100% of
making it a clear and kind of un muddy
to waters for the veterans and I hope I
get all your support on that I really do
any
questions thank you representative sudor
questions for representative
sudor seeing none thank you for your
input thank
you so I have two more pink cards and I
will if possible I'd like to conclude
this hearing in the next few minutes so
that we can take a lunch break
um I have M Mo Mora Ryan that would like
welcome I don't make these for short
people um my name is Mora Ryan and I am
a veteran US Army retired in addition to
being an advocate for veterans in our
state when we were having our debates
before our elections a common theme that
came up was that veterans were not able
to get sufficient support for tax
credits
um the cost of the VA compensation of
pension has been rising but at a very
low rate and not in accordance with the
keeping of
inflation which has been tough for many
veterans because many of them have said
that they won't be able to stay in their
houses even though they are 100%
disabled um passions of this bill would
allow towns to allow 100% disabled
veterans have 100% ta property tax
exemption
there was similar language passed by
both the house and the uh the Senate of
this body that had an administrative
Chevron rule put on it which essentially
said that if you didn't have an sah
grant that you could not have that even
though the the Department of Veterans
Affairs actually sent out paperwork
saying if you are 100% disabled veteran
report to your tax office and turn over
your paperwork so as we know from the
Supreme Court these administrative rules
are not supposed to be as restrictive or
as over overwhelming as they have become
however um I think this language is
appropriate because there are people who
cannot guess get sah grants because
there's a limit on the amount of money
so there may only be one available for
the State of New Hampshire in any given
year and there are many people veterans
who go through other organizations like
homes for their troops to get their
houses modified so I absolutely 100%
support this bill I know this bill came
forward in another form in the past at
which point representative miss Shay had
said that some towns haven't increased
their veterans tax credit since the
Civil War which is not appropriate we
need to support our veterans and as for
the difference of 100% disabled veterans
there's scheduler veterans and there's
tdiu veterans tdiu veterans are 100%
disabled and are unable to work which
means they cannot be gainfully employed
in any way scheduled veterans have had
injuries so severe that they um they
basically overrun the VA math system
and they're going to be 100% but the
100% rating is not guaranteed forever
you only have it and the VA re-evaluates
you periodically and you can lose that
rating so this is not necessarily a
permanent component and I'd ask you to
bear that in mind because many people
for example if a veteran has
debilitating cancer and cannot work they
could be 100% rated but that may only be
during their treatment and at that point
it may terminate and they may go to
another level so I'd like you to
consider that as well because this 100%
rating is never permanent it's always up
subject to review so um I'm available
for any questions I do support this 100%
I do believe it is necessary I do
believe there are many veterans who are
struggling they have made their voices
clear during the election when they came
and expressed their
interests so I would ask for your
support for that thank you Miss Ryan and
I appreciate your
support or I meant what I meant you
support the bill and I appreciate your
service that's what I meant I understand
okay questions
for representative
frock thank you madam chair
um I am at this point very
confused the amendment to the bill talks
about
100% reduction or exemption of the
veterans property tax and I've heard a
lot of testimony from you and others
about 100% disability and what
percentage of disability can you
straighten me out on this please so
could you clarify your question for me
do you want to know what 100% disability
entails no I am ask I what I am asking
is what is the relationship between the
veteran disability and the amendment to
this bill which is
for a percentage of the property tax
okay
um basically from my perspective this
gives a a municipality or a town the
ability
to change or increase the veterans tax
credit if they vote to do
so based off criteria that they see fit
I mean there are many people
who essentially went to the VA to try
and get additional tax credit because
the VA put out a directive saying that
you could and then found out that no
there were these administrative rules
that were restricting it and I think
that we don't need to have
administrative rules to restrict
it I'm not sure I'm answering your
sure um that make it so I'm
just yes you can have a you can have a
followup but we need to remember that we
we need to speak to and I think that
that that's what you're getting at the
amended language in the bill and and
nothing else because what is before us
the change has to do with the upper
bound of this property um tax credit not
any other um criteria so chair no thank
you for clarifying that uh that was
going to be the essence of my question I
appreciate that further
questions seeing none thank thank you
for coming here today we appreciate it
um I apologize I didn't mean to say
something else which was just that there
are only 71 households eligible for this
tax credit in my town and the um
somebody had asked about the assessors
Association but it's
0.004% of the
budget thank
you the last pink card that I have
cor three minutes or less if possible
for for your U my name is Adam denor I'm
here representing the Department of
Revenue Administration uh the department
doesn't have a policy or a position on
this particular piece of policy although
there is one technical issue a
percentage credit of any kind between
one and 100 is not actually workable in
the tax rate calculation
we need to know when we go to set a tax
rate the amount of the credit at the
time that we calculate it um so
basically the the tax rate calculation
can be distilled down to a numerator
which is your tax levy your
Appropriations less revenues and a
denominator which is your tax base uh
the uh credit works as an additional
amount of appropriation it's an amount
of money that the town's going to have
to raise in excess of what they would
normally need to raise in order to cover
for the folks that will not be paying it
if we don't know know that appropriation
amount at the time that we calculate the
rate uh we can't calculate a rate
additionally since that credit amount is
dependent on the rate that's then
calculated it creates a circular
calculation that will constantly regress
um forever so the way to accomplish a um
removing the tax bill for a property is
through an exemption not through a
credit so this bill will at least need
some amendment to reference the
possibility that municipality could
adopt a full property tax exemption
rather than a 100%
credit and and I there I just want to
make one other point there's been I
think some cross-pollination here with
72 36a and 7235 7235 the the key part of
it is that total and permanent service
connected disability when a when a
municipality receives an application
they are looking for that specific
designation on this measure so the one
the the you know 100 or 50% disability
is on a separate statute this one in
particular 7235 is specifically about um
total and permanent service connected
disability thank you questions for Mr
Devan
core representative Colby just really
quick do you recall I know you wouldn't
have numbers for
20124 uh but in
2023 do you recall the total number uh
of um exemptions or credits that were
awarded under 7235 yes I I don't
although I could email the committee I
could find that rather quickly and email
it over okay thank you thank you that
would that would be great if you could
questions seeing none is there anyone
else present in the room who wishes to
speak to this bill who hasn't had the
opportunity to do so
yet seeing none I am going to close the
hearing on House Bill
99 so as you can see committee
members we're behind schedule and we are
due to be back here to continue with
hearings at 1:00 I I I do apologize for
my um rookie scheduling with this first
hearing I will try to do better in the
future um so yeah
please get some lunch and we will look
you
e
good afternoon everyone the time is now
10:6 p.m. and we are only six minutes
behind schedule at this point so we have
three bills scheduled for this afternoon
and the first
bill I will going to open up the hearing
on House Bill 101 relative to exempting
certain elderly homeowners from paying
property
taxes so with us to introduce the bill
is representative
Belcher thank you madam chairwoman
members of the committee uh firstly let
me say ahead of time if my phone were to
go off I sincerely apologize nor
normally I would never keep it on but I
am expecting my wife to go into labor
you fair so we'll get through this
fairly quickly I think uh the record
representative beler Carol County
District 4
Wakefield uh this bill is designed to
create a light at the end of the tunnel
it is an effort to create a set of
circumstances tied to Advanced age under
which you would no longer have to pay a
yearly rent check to the government just
to keep the home that you probably
already own
outright I have serious concerns about
the Financial Health of many seniors in
our current
Society let me just say it plainly the
official inflation numbers are a
carefully curated
fiction everyone who experiences a
grocery bill understands this
real inflation which is likely closer
than to 20% than the advertised
5% significantly
outpaces the retirement income of very
many seniors who in many cases income is
based on official inflation
statistics likewise the value of their
properties in recent years has soared
which in many cases has been coupled
with increases in government spending
which causes taxes to
soar I do not want to see our seniors
being evicted from the modest homes they
already own because they can't afford
outrageous taxes being levied on
them however I also recognize that rapid
and sharp uh decreases in local revenues
could be a problem which is why there's
many specifics in this bill designed to
limit the initial impact on towns and of
legislation this bill would
exempt up to
$530,000 which is the at least at the
time of putting this bill in the current
median home price in the state from
valuation for those seniors age 72 plus
who have been a persistent New Hampshire
resident for 10 or more years
and who have been a owner or co-owner of
the property they seek the exemption on
for two or more years now I think those
caveats were important to put in they
were the result of speaking with a
number of other reps and addressing
certain concerns certainly I don't want
to encourage those from our neighboring
states who have spent most of their
lives in high tax High government
service areas to Simply jump over the
Border buy a home live taxfree while
encouraging higher taxes on everyone
else that's not the point of this the
point is to affect those long-term New
Hampshire residents who have lived here
worked here raised families here who are
rooted here to give them an end point
circumstances towns won't be taking huge
hits by seeing that $10 million
lakefront property Exempted from for the
full amount of the property either it's
only up to that
$530,000 that would be Exempted and only
that portion of any property that is
basis finally I know that the concern
has been brought to me that this would
simply shift the tax burden from elderly
persons to younger families which have a
which might have a detrimental impact I
don't entirely disagree except it kind
of misses the fundamental point that
we're dealing with a problem of excess
spending excess
Taxation and we really ought to be
looking first to cut spending rather
than simply shift it off to somebody
else of course that would all be at the
making
lastly while this would have a revenue
negative impact in the obvious sense if
adopted it would have a revenue positive
impact in some less obvious sense namely
this would
incentivize families keeping older
parents in the home to properly care for
them in a loving environment where they
really probably would rather be than
someplace like a County nursing
home so with that I will end and I will
happy to take questions thank
you thank you repres representative
Belcher questions for the prime sponsor
I see representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question
um what about a 72 year-old person or
above who is a still working still
working at a very highly paid job and
worth uh thank you for the question
there is no such test
in this bill as such it doesn't
discriminate against somebody who is
working versus not working it simply
says at this Advanced age you've been
here you've met the qualifications of
living here 10 years of living in this
home of being listed as a property owner
on the property for two plus years those
you um the chair recognizes
I hope you're laughing with
me thank you madam chairman um do you
happen to know the average
Americans thank you for the question I
don't off thought I Hadad know the
average lifespan of Americans I did in
part of drafting this bill look of the
average lifespan for New Hampshire
residents it varies by male and female
but if I'm I'm not mistaken it was
you further questions representative
frock thank you madam
chair
um this tax
exemption applies to
homeowners
now if I was a
renter I would be paying my I would be
paying property taxes through the
rent and this does not
address uh that portion of my rent that
goes to property tax could you tell me
why that is
fair thank you for the question first um
not exactly correct because uh renters
are not directly paying property tax if
you mean that it's a pass through from
the rent presumably yes they would be
paying for the owner's proper prop tax
as as a part of renting this does not
address um renters this addresses
property owners only and I don't see any
reasonably um simple way that you could
address a renter in a in a position like
that thank
you further questions I see
representative
majori thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um you create
in this bill a definition for residents
um there are existing in current law in
RSA 216 and
654 definitions for residents I'm
curious if there was consideration of of
those definitions or if this definition
was specific for any reason I'm curious
why the why another new definition thank
you that that's a that is a good
question uh so first of all the
definition of um residence in this bill
would only apply in this bill it
wouldn't be a broader than that set of
circumstances and it was specifically
because there was some confusion in the
lawyerly language in trying to address
the specific set of circumstances I was
looking to exempt namely that it would
not include any commercial or
non-residential portion of any property
the valuation on that um it would only
be applicable to the residential portion
of any property so that's the reason
there further question questions
representative
Gilman thank you madam chairman thank
you for taking my
question excuse me I I want to follow up
on representative Major's uh question in
that residents shall exclude attached
dwelling units if we're trying to keep
families is
there do don't you think there's a
scenario where that elderly folk might
want to live separately from their
younger family members so a dwelling
unit accessory dwelling unit would be
the solution for them yes and thank you
for the question um if if you look at
the structure of the sentence in which
we're looking at right now which is page
one uh 14 line 14
on it's not seeking to um exempt all
accessory dwelling units it's only
looking to to exempt those dwelling
units that are commercial or otherwise
property
okay thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Dolan thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question as
I as I read the the
uh law as as you brought it Forward uh
is I'm concerned about so-called gaming
the system
and uh what I'm talking about is you
know how do
we
prevent uh go getting Grandma and having
her move in with you so that you can now
exploit the the uh the exemption if
she's been living in the state for over
10 years have you have you given any
thought
to um instead of living in the the
residents being living in the state for
10 years how about living at the address
for over 10
years thank you for that question and my
answer will be a little bit complicated
but first I want to I want to flip the
concept and say I'm not actually trying
to prevent that circumstance I'm trying
to incentivize that circumstance because
I would like to see our elderly being
cared for by family members if possible
however there is there is within this
bill the 2-year period of time during
which the Exempted sinking person must
be listed as a owner on the property in
question before they would be eligible
for um for that exemption
followup yes the reason I asked that
question is as I have seen in many cases
the other end of the age Spectrum where
kids are moving in with
Grandma uh in order
to um gain name the the school location
say that well you you can go to our
school in our in our town uh and I know
this is not what you're proposing but
it's on the same concept of gaming the
system you you can gain the address as
long as you sleep in that in that house
two or three nights a week you now can
can go to school and absorb the tax uh
consequences of of uh
getting schooled in our community
without actually owning a home or living
in the in the community uh for very long
and I I'm just concerned about gaming
the system in order to get around some
of these L thank you I I think I can
respond to the specific circumstance
you're looking at actually I think it
would disincentivize something like that
from happening because under current
circumstances an elderly person um with
no tax exemption uh would seemingly have
a greater incentive to have a grandson
granddaughter move in with them to
potentially help
financially um then they might be if
they receive the exemption and didn't
need the financial support um but in
either case there's no concrete barrier
to a grandchild or child moving in with
them to utilize the the school district
so I don't think that specifically is
applicable to this but the broader
context I think it it does reverse and
disincentivizes it thank
you representative Walker
yes uh the definition of homeowner is a
little ambiguous to me but because what
if uh I'm an elderly person I have my
house in a trust so my name's no longer
on the deed the trust is or if I turn it
over to my son or daughter or whatever
and I have lifetime tency that's not
addressed in this as
well correct and and thank you for the
question and that was on purpose um
because a trust is already an instrument
designed to um limit tax burdens under
certain circumstances the idea was not
to further incentivize trust but to
incentivize an owner just your average
your average elderly person um to be
home further
questions representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you again for taking another
question I'm stuck on the number 72
somehow that doesn't ring the elderly
Bell for me and I'm wondering why you
chose that number thank you for the
question um that's a very good question
actually it almost seems arbitrary
except there was an awful lot of
research put in um in order to try to
balance the desire to limit the taxing
of of elderly persons to allow them to
stay in their home versus the immediate
the chair rep recognizes representative
Colby thank you
chair um
so in
2023 and you probably saw this in all
your research uh
$1.1
billion uh was
Exempted uh for through the elderly
exemptions that exist in
municipalities um that's Statewide
we also see that
uh the number of adults that are aged 60
to 64 years old and 65 to 69 years old
are
the highest percentage of population in
the state what are the projections if
of how much that 1.1 million will or
increase uh thank you for the question I
I don't have an easy answer for that
it's complicated for a lot of reasons
first of which is you
can't even in the maximalist sense you
can't just assume that every person who
would qualify would take this and that
would increase the burden because a lot
of these people are already probably
receiving tax exemptions under current
exemptions so you would have to
calculate that into the into the full
picture I have no doubt that it would
increase it by exactly how much I don't
know
Murphy thank you madam chair
representative y72 uh there are people
now early onset Alzheimer's or other
types of dementia and that can happen
anyways between ages 58 plus um is there
any exemption for
that thank you for the question uh just
to be clear this this bill is in no way
targeted toward uh disability or any
other status I believe those already
exist in law um as it currently is this
is designed as a blanket Universal age
72 plus and the number I'm not
necessarily married to the number if the
committee wanted to alter the number
somewhat that's that's within your
purview um but it's not it's not
designed to be a disability uh exemption
representative Guthrie has a
question thank you madam chair and I
apologize for being late and a question
may have already been asked but uh it
wasn't answered for me so thank you for
taking my question representative I
don't see any reference to
Financial in this bill no Financial
requirement on the petitioner for an
abatement is is that on purpose
so thank you for the question yes the
the point of this bill the point of
introducing this was not to create yet
another Progressive means tested tax
exemption this was to meant to create a
blanket exemption based on age and
length of residency and the other
factors that were
involved followup Madam chair yes is it
clear to me uh to should it be clear to
me that if I'm 72 or older and I own the
exemption thank you for the question
well if you also have been a 10year plus
New Hampshire resident two years plus on
the property you're seeking the
exemption for and your local government
adopts this provision then yes thank you
very much thank you madam chair are
there any further
questions seeing none thank you for for
you next I have Mr Michael
branley from the town of Swansea is he
here no he's not here
oh okay so we will go to Mr bro Dees
from
nhma awesome um thank you so much uh mad
M chairwoman and thank you to the
committee again again Brody des's from
the Hampshire Municipal
Association um we are opposed to the
bill um I know it's a local option but
we do have in our legislative policy
positions um that I handed out in our
statements of belief set um we don't
just support every local option that the
legislature seeks to provide and we have
some um concerns with this legislation
as written and if a town were to adopt
it due to several um gray areas let me
just get my notes open so I don't forget
anything um well first is the tax burden
ship that's something that many of you
have served in this committee for you
know you know numerous terms would
recognize that we usually come forward
and mention that um there would be a
large tax burden shift from those who
would now be Exempted from paying
property taxes to those who will have to
continue paying property taxes um it's
not quite clear how big that burden
shift would be but based on the fact
that there's not any means testing to
this property tax exemption like most of
ours do in the state of New Hampshire if
could be a very broad uh group of
property taxpayers that would all of a
sudden um
$530,000 of their assessed property
value would be Exempted from Taxation
and all of that would have to shift to
those who don't qualify for the tax so
those um who don't meet the
qualifications of this bill regarding um
state residency duration um duration in
the residence and also um the other
duration requirement um it's also a
little bit confusing and ambiguous um in
section 2 uh subsection b um the
exemption language it's there's an
exemption to the exemption is kind of
what we talked about internally and we
believe would be very tough for some of
our assessors whether it's private or um
your assessing Department if you have
your own assessor hired in House at a
municipality to um interpret this and
there'd be a lot of reporting
requirements for property owners and
assessors would have to really chase
down those reporting requirements think
about the um the charitable and Rel just
tax exemption where organizations have
to fill it an A9 and an a12 you would
have to have similar reporting
requirements for something like this um
there is also an existing elderly tax
exemption RSA 72 col
39-a um and in you know with most of our
tax exemption statutes in the state of
Hampshire if I'm not mistaken all there
are means testing so you know you have
to make under a certain amount in salary
per year and have a certain amount of um
of assets that are considered and there
is reporting requirements to the towns
and ultimately to Department of Revenue
Administration so due to some of the
ambiguities in how you would be
essentially determining someone's
residence the um the amount of reporting
requirements to go to those different
property owners and figure out if they
really do um meet the qualifications to
meet this uh this tax exemption um in
some towns it would just be extremely
difficult for them to apply this law and
yes it is a local option but with any
local option it could be petition worn
article so a town could say well we're
100% % not sure that we could implement
this properly or be able to have the
capacity to make sure it's done
correctly and um you know tax exemptions
are popular no one likes paying taxes
but we recognize we have to pay taxes
for um basic services that Society needs
to function and there'd be a fear that
all of a sudden that tax burden for
paying for those basic functions of
society would be shifted to one
classification of taxpayers versus
another um so for for those reasons um
the Hampshire Municipal Association is
opposed and I'd be happy to answer
answer any questions or clarify anything
if people um yes thank you Mr Dees the
chair recognizes representative
Guthrie thank you Mo Madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh
would you believe that in my town two uh
years in a row there was an article in
the warrant that do exactly this and IR
rationale was these people have already
paid for for their children actually it
was just taking the school part of the
budget not the rest of the school part
of the uh cost not just not the town but
is this a sort of a backdoor thing to do
that is the rationale for this bill or
could the rationale for this bill to be
accepted based on the these elderly
people like me have already paid their
share to the community they've lived in
for 10 years and are entitled to not
have to pay for the running of the town
from now on because they've paid their
dues thank you for your question
representative um I can't speak to the
intent of the bill in so far as what the
um the sponsor has explained to you guys
what his intent is um I can say though
that everyone in a municipality utilizes
Municipal services to varying degrees
and no matter their age so you know for
example an ambulance service you know
municipality is going to have a contract
with a ambulance service or going to
want to have their own in-house
ambulance service because while it might
be more likely that someone who is older
might need the ambulance more than me I
still will need an ambulance if I fall
and break my leg so it's good for at
least our position for everyone to be
contributing towards the services that
they all utilize thank
you the chair before we proceed the
chair has a reminder for committee
members would you believe questions are
not permitted in this committee and I
will we'll give representative Guthrie
one pass on that I'm entitled thank you
yes you
[Laughter]
are the chair recognizes representative
majori thank you madam chair and thank
you Mr Shan for taking my question um as
you stated we already have an elderly
tax exemption in statute 793 uh 7239 a
if this were to if this bill in front of
us were to pass and it were to be
adopted in a town would would this do do
you believe and does nhma believe that
these would
act together or would it be one or the
other or would it just be
conflict that would um that's a very
good question I think the way we would
interpret it is that they would work
together but um that's honestly may be a
better question for the Department of
Revenue administration's Council um they
might want to weigh in on something like
this but but um I think our our personal
position and our take would be that this
would they would be together so you
could apply for the existing um elderly
tax exemption under
72 39-a and then there would be this
additional one that again is very broad
so you'd have um you know it's you can't
know what you don't know so we don't
know how many people would be able to
qualify for this but just looking at and
how broad it is and there being no
income or asset um means testing it
would be a lot of people and it would
depend on municipality too for example
wolfboro we have an average um we have a
higher average age than most
municipalities so me being a younger
taxpayer I might get whacked a little
bit harder if this was implemented in my
town further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so
much so um One Last Call for Mr Michael
brandley is he
is there anyone else here present in the
room who wishes to speak to this bill
who hasn't had the opportunity to do
so okay seeing none I will close the
[Applause]
we have a handout that's coming around
we also have an amendment to this bill
that's being passed
okay the clerk is all sorted out so at
this time I would like to open the
hearing on House Bill 110 authorizing
counties to establish revolving fund
accounts and with us this afternoon we
have representative Traer who is the
Prime sponsor to introduce this bill
government good afternoon Madam chair
and members of this Comm committee I am
representative Douglas Traer out of
belnap County District 8 representing
the towns of Belmont Tilton and
singon sorry about the delay on the
amendment that was just finished about
an hour
ago um today I come forward with House
Bill 110 with an amendment which has
been
presented which would allow County
government to establish a revolving
expense fund line for the purpose of
special details also known as private um
services or paid
services this is a common sense bill
which will allow counties government to
establish a revolving expense line for
special
details as our local and State uh
entities already have the um this under
their um Wing they're able to um perform
this this bill is not a a required bill
it will be up to each County to decide
if they would like to uh
participate um if this um bill becomes
law
the way the county law is written now it
does not allow County government to
adopt this practice which becomes a
burden on
taxpayers if this bill is passed in the
County government across the state
chooses to participate it would allow
department heads to reduce their budgets
by not having to request large
Appropriations in certain
lines which will in turn save taxpayers
is money this bill would allow
significant lower funding in certain
lines knowing it will be replenished
when revenue is collected for services
provided outside the normal duties or
requirements of law enforcement agencies
department heads would not need to
request additional funding for the
County
Commissioners um in the um process or in
the event that they overspend that line
item
many Sheriff's departments across the
state have been requested by local and
state law enforcement agencies to assist
with patrol coverage and private paid
outside
details due to the shortage of Manpower
or the inability to hire
offices these agencies are relying on
county level um law enforcement agencies
to assist with coverage and Public
Safety whereby county law
enforcement has Statewide
jurisdictions however under the current
law if the fund are
expended
um County Law Enforcement must refuse to
provide these Services if they did not
have the funds to do so um to ensure the
safety okay fostering Economic
Development and ensuring critical
infrastructure is not
delayed yes the department head may go
before the County Commissioners or
delegation to ask for more money which
would delay um deputies or law
enforcement at the county level to be
able to uh perform these extra duties
due to the shortage of funds for an
example say if a private company that is
working on a bridge here in New
Hampshire or any other state around us
and have to come through New Hampshire
there are um dot rules that require that
they get permits and that they hire law
enforcement to escort them which under
the rule it says State
Police where there's shortage at State
Police they have been relying on County
agencies to provide these services to
ensure the products get to their job
site in a timely
fashion um whereas I said the counties
do not have a revolving fund they budget
for a certain amount amount and if that
is spent at that point they have to turn
jobs um at this point you know that's
pretty much the um T of the bill it is
not mandatory that any County
participates but it's their option if
they would like to with this type of um
fund for an example if all of a sudden
um say a county says we're going to give
you $20,000
we know that's going to be there once
they bill out to these private
companies and they pay back they'll keep
that the money will go back whatever
they use to keep that level of $20,000
funding and the rest would go into the
general fund to help offset cost um and
taxes so I ask this committee to please
pass House Bill 110 and allow County
government the right to establish
revolving funds as municipal state
agencies are already doing thank you and
I will take questions thank you
representative Traer for your bill
sponsor representative Walker yes thank
you madam
shair revolving funds so what if I'm a
county well that's if I over over
appropriate into that revolving fund can
that money be shifted to another another
AG or another uh project or
department so if I understand you right
so if all of a sudden a county decides
they're going to give $20,000 for that
revolving fund correct correct and at
that
point if they hire outside details for
offices that 20,000 will always be there
any extra money that is earned will go
to the general fund
and at that point it'll be up to the
Commissioners and or delegations to um
appropriate that money at the
appropriate
times the chair recognizes
representative Colby thank you um who
would you be proposing the authorized
agents would be to expend those
funds so for an example the sheriff's
department at the you know their budget
process they'll have a line item named
under you know a detail expending uh
expenditure and at that point it'll be
up to the sheriff to authorize his
employees to be able to work these
details but that would be through the
Commissioners the delegation at the time
will determine you know during their
budget process if they agree with the
amount that the department head has
requested
representative
Guthrie thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question it it isn't
clear to
me uh how the money gets taken out of
the
reserve fund revolving fund it's uh I
know we use the same system at at the
Town level in many
cases tell you the truth I don't
particularly like care about it but
that's a it seems like SL a slush fund
but who would who would have the
authority to take the money out of this
reol fund and pay for what you're trying
to do which is actually still operating
correct so good question um
representative so basically at that
point once a a deputy puts in a pay slip
saying he worked this detail it goes
through the HR department and it'll be
part of their pay so basically the
sheriff or the super visor in charge of
that will say yes this Deputy worked it
approved it it'll be part of um his uh
or his or her weekly pay and the HR
department will take that money out of
that fund follow up Madam chair yes
thank you uh isn't this really a uh a
budget outside the budget if you will
that it's just a separate means of
paying things
and the money going in comes out of the
tax levy or whatever but isn't it just a
a different way of paying your bills I
would say no on that basically it will
be a line item that is agreed upon by
the County Commissioners and the
delegation
um it's a line item in the budget to pay
for outside details or private details
that in return the private companies
will pay back and it
will go back into that line item to the
maximum um amount that the Comm uh
commission or delegation has agreed upon
for an example if all of a sudden the
during the budget session they say we're
going to give you
$20,000 for outside
details at that point that $220,000 will
pay for the salaries and the um stuff of
the deputies that
work once that private company that
hired the deputies for the um special
detail that will go back into that fund
and the remainder will go back into the
general budget thank you thank you madam
chair thank you the chair recognizes
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um how does
the fund get established
so basically thank you for your question
representative um so originally the town
will have to adopt this saying yes we
fund yes follow up you said the town but
we're talking about counties Sor County
I'm sorry my mistake it's County
Commission so go back to my question how
would the fund get established so
basically the the um department head
would ask the um County Commission is
during their budget to establish a
revolving fund
line so it would have to be voted on by
the Commissioners and that amount of
money they agree upon will have to go
into the budget and be reviewed by the
um
questions representative
grund yes thank you madam chair and and
thank you for taking my question um so I
know what you just explained but in here
it says by vote of the legislative body
establish a revolving budget expense
line so who is the legislative body what
is it the county delegation is it uh is
a quick question is that in the
amendment or is that in the original
because in in the handout we just
so the legislative body in my thoughts
would be the commission is to accept the
uh or accept this and adopt it as one of
their rules but the um review will be
from the
delegation you know if they agree with
the amount that they put in to the
budget
representative
France does this mean that there's only
one
initial deposit into this account from
the county
budget when you establish the account
yes there'll be one deposit into that
out of taxpayers funds correct thank
you further
questions representative gr thank you
again Madam chair and um I don't know if
you know this but maybe you do so if
there's line item transfers from
different accounts can money be
transferred out of this public safety
account to another
account and then this would be
reestablished with the fund so you're
essentially
moving funding elsewhere accidentally so
if I'm understanding you're right yes
they can like a department head can go
to the Commissioners and ask them to
take money out of the unanticipated fund
line right I'm I'm asking more about out
of the public safety blind item fund
let's say okay okay if they need money
for heating can they transfer money out
of public that Public Safety fund line
item to a heating line item and now
you're reesta now you're refunding that
account
with other Revenue that's see how you
transferred expense elsewhere that's my
concern I mean that would be up to the
Commissioners I believe if that's how
they want to do it biggest thing here is
just keeping a certain amount in this
line and once any um revenues brought in
above that amount it goes into the
general fund I believe the Commissioners
can decide what they want to do with
it the chair recognizes representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you once again for taking yet another
question so following up on that
previous question in Roman numeral 3
it says the provisions of this section
shall not preclude the establishment of
revolving fund for any other purpose
authorized by law that confuses me does
that mean that you could establish five
revolving funds if you have different
purposes does it mean that funds from
the initial revolving fund can be moved
to this revolving fund what does that
um that's a good question I would have
to look into that a little bit more and
think about it um because I believe this
was um the my intent was just to have
this fund but at that point once it goes
into the general fund I believe the
commissions if they to say we want to do
you next I have a pink card from a Mr
Jim
McIntire good afternoon manam chair
members of the committee my name is uh
Jim McIntyre I'm the chief Deputy of
bnap County Sheriff's Department um I
was told to keep it simple uh so I can
surely do that for you operationally is
why I'm here to testify um the New
Hampshire Sheriff's Association is in
support of adopting this bill um the the
the problem comes with County government
is it becomes different than municipal
government we currently provide a line
item for outside details as projected
and that projection is done on best
guess scenario so um we have regular
details that the sheriff's office would
typically um uh handle such as um things
like the Mount Washington or things at
um in Bap County specifically the um
Gunstock ski area uh and so forth what
we're finding is um more more
departments um state and local
departments are needing supplemental
help they don't have the manpower to do
them so we've actually found ourselves
supplementing their their forces in many
capacities could be Patrol shifts and we
have departments that don't have enough
um manpower to cover 24-hour protection
they hire our deputies to work those as
details when we pay these they come out
of our line item of outside details
which for a number purpose we had set at
$45,000 last year we spent approximately
$90,000 to cover that so we're
overexpanded in that line item there's
no provision for us to recover that
money and keep paying details we have to
go before the Commissioners and ask for
a line transfer or a supplemental
appropriation neither one is desirable
this is a hope to to basically um have
some seed money from the current line
item which would be essentially the um
$20,000 that representative charia
mentioned that would be the seed money
to start the fund and then as vendors
pay their uh pay their bills back that
would replenish that $20,000 therefore
we'd never go below the 20,000 but there
is a residual when you work uh these
details um the officer gets paid the
benefits get paid retirement gets paid
um maintenance and fuel gets paid and
then there's uh a residual that would
then go into the general fund so I don't
know if I'm answering some of the
questions I heard earlier but the the
process for the
Overture still goes to the general fund
as it currently
does the what this would eliminate is
our Sheriff overex spending a line item
um that he guesses or us asking for more
money
that we don't need which would then also
go either to another line or general
fund
so does that help explain some of the
questions I kind of jump forward but I I
feel like there's a lot of questions
fresh and uh I may have some operational
answers well thank you sir um one thing
could you amend your card you said that
you were in support of this bill I did
could you amend your card and initial it
please well I'm going to pass it or when
you're done we'll pass it around and
absolutely questions representative
Guthrie thank you madam
chair with and thank you for taking my
question and I hope you take it in the
right light it seems like with all due
respect it looks like you got a real
problem between your staff and the
Commissioners you'll have a line item
that you can't trans you can transfer um
as as for there is a process for to
recover that $40,000 that you need for
details is that correct there is no
process that's what this bill addresses
sir um the the monies that we recover go
direct to the general fund as a as a
revenue so that's what we're trying to
recover but we can be
directed um in essence to overspend that
line
but that's that's the question as are we
allowed to overspend the line or is
there a law that can Rectify it um this
law parallels what municipalities do
with revolving funds and I I believe
that clarifying it would would leave
less guess work and um be a better
accounting practice followup Madam chair
yes representative isn't there a better
solution which would be that your
Commissioners when they're looking at
their their budget and the legislative
body is looking at their leget
originally that they actually realized
that you're underfunding that line so
much so that you're going to have
trouble before the end of the year would
it be better to have that line
stronger so to yes we've we've doubled
that line this year but to
representative charer Point that's going
to have to be funded by the taxpayers
through appropriation so they will fund
80,00
this year versus $20,000 seed so that's
where it's a savings to the to the
taxpayer thank
you further questions representative
majori thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question and testify
I'm curious I I think I understand who
County employees are but I'm not quite
sure that I understand who volunteers
are acting outside of the ordinary
detail of such I believe that that's
language to cover outside detail um
duties uh where sheriff's deputies are
performing you know rits and precepts
from the court anything outside of that
job description would be a voluntary
outside Duty I believe that's what that
language is trying to capture yeah okay
thank you additional
questions representative
Gerard thank you madam chair Sheriff I
know you just stated that you are now
putting $80,000 into your expenditure
line I
if I'm not mistaken you're going to have
$80,000 also on your Revenue line item
because you're going to be collecting
back for that line item as well is that
not correct yes sir and I would love
those discussions to be had in parallel
but they never want to talk about
revenues at the same time they talk
about expenses thank you thank you does
anybody else have a
question seeing none thank you thank you
okay so I do not have any additional
pink cards is there anybody present in
the room who wishes to speak to this
bill who has not had the opportunity to
do
so seeing none I will close the hearing
okay the clerk is is ready here
so I would like to open the public
hearing on House Bill 78 requiring a
person to have a domicile in the
district from which they serve as county
commissioner with us this afternoon we
have representative turot welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chair hello members of the
municipal and County it looks like there
are more new members to this committee
than there are old members uh good to be
here good to see you all um I am here to
introduce HB
78 uh which is really a simple addition
uh to correct an oversight in a bill
from last term and for those who of you
who are not not here I'm going to just
give you a brief history of what that
bill did so it kind of gives you an idea
of where we are and what we're doing
here so up until last term um in the
state of New Hampshire nine out of the
10 counties elected
their um Commissioners by district
straford county was the only one that
elected them at large in other words the
entire County elected all three
Commissioners well we put in a bill last
term uh that actually districted uh
straford County for the first time and
that went
through
um when it came time for the election
filings we had two individuals file for
one of the districts District
3 and what happened with that is one of
the individuals actually lived outside
the district now again the whole intent
of the bill that we had put in was to
have the individual Commissioners
representing their
District so when um the other individual
in that District
3 actually filed an election uh a
complaint with the election law
committee we went to that and the issue
um again was ended up coming over you'll
see in the in the bill in front of you
RSA
6559 and and although the commissioner
the ballot lock
commission individuals actually agreed
with us they they didn't approve it
because they said they didn't believe it
was in their
jurisdiction so what we are doing here
is
putting let's back up a little bit um
when we did I think I said at the very
beginning Here We There Was An oversight
um
and 6559 was in a different section of
the rsas than the the area where we
actually districted straford
County so that one uh you'll see in the
the bill that I put forward uh basically
in section one it just adds And straford
to clarify that that all yeah also in
straford county that you have to be a a
resident of that you must be domiciled
um and that was the issue we went before
the ballot law commission they said yeah
we we agree with you but we don't
believe we have the authority to change
it so we're here to do that um there
were different ways we could have
skinned the cat to get this
accomplished uh but I think the easiest
way was just to add straford into the
list of the other nine uh counties there
so that's what you see the second part
of that uh starting on line eight you'll
see where it says application straford
County that's a lot of language that
basically says what is
currently um the individual that was
currently elected will re continue to be
uh that commissioner even though he
lives out of the district which by the
way I believe it's the only I don't know
if it's the first time but it's the only
individual who actually represent a dis
represents a district that he doesn't
live in I don't think that's ever
happened before which is why we need to
correct it um
but that uh that second section starting
on Eight Is is what that do a lot of
wording that basically says what is is
and this will not change until the
election uh the next general election in
2026 now I understand Senator gray will
present you with an amendment to this
I've read through it and I would highly
recommend you do adopt it um it it
clarifies the section A little bit more
um
better um than currently exists so I
would recommend when he passes that out
to you um that you consider it U before
it gets over to his Committee in the
Senate I believe that's all I
have my brain is still somewhere over
Europe and my body's here but my brain's
over Europe so I hopefully I did
everything you needed or said everything
you needed to hear certainly take any
questions thank you representative turot
for that introduction I have a quick
question sure could you refresh our my
memory and those who were here
previously what is the bill number in
the year that you're you're referring to
the old one you mean correct yeah I
don't have that in front of me it was
last it was 2024
though what was it 70 M 75 thank you so
it the the original one though that was
filed I don't it was an hp75 because if
you all remember it got stuck in
committee because it was uh
retained uh but it ended up being on
hp75 questions for the prime sponsor the
chair recognizes representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um a couple
times in your testimony you referenced
um District to be domiciled in the
district but in the bill it says in the
county
um looks like line three so I I see what
you're saying so in the first part of
that you you'll see starting on line two
going through line four it talks to
Commissioners sheriffs County attorneys
uh County treasures reg talks to a whole
slew of people and it says that they
they must be
uh must have a domicile in the county he
was chosen then it goes on to talk about
County Commissioner where it's more
specific where it says person must have
a domicile in the district so the first
part of it is more all-encompassing for
the county the second part is just for
the
questions okay I have a question sure so
see it pertains to vacancies so that
that would be in the the section two
applicab application MH if um lines 11
12 and on it says if there shall be a
vacancy in a commissioner district for
any reason prior to the 2026 state
general election the vacancy shall be
filled as provided in law for straford
County Commissioners that existed for
the 2024 state general election so that
that vacancy shall be filled by the
county
delegation no um it would be filled in
the same way as in other words what
that's that line is saying is because
right now we um in straford County
somebody can
live in the domicile outside the
district which he's running for for that
that would continue should a vacancy
occur that's that's what that line
refers to I understand that what I'm
trying to get at is who fills a
vacancy I would I would say that would
be probably an election yeah I I don't
know but I would say it was probably an
election no excuse me um yeah
only individuals that the chair
recognizes shall speak what I'm getting
at is it is my understanding that the
the body that would fill that vacancy
would be the county delegation as a
whole so my question is is that what you
really want or because now you have
three Commissioners that are in three
different
districts would it not be perhaps um a
better idea to have those delegates from
that District
elect the replacement and not the entire
County
delegation no um and I think uh rep uh
Senator Gray's Amendment will actually
speak to this perfect thank you further
questions seeing none I appreciate you
Bill thank you madam chair my name is
James Gray I'm a senator from District
Six uh representing Alton gilmon all the
way down Route 11 to Rochester and
Strafford uh just one correction the
what you've got in front of you is not
an amendment for your committee it is
what I will submit in my committee if
you pass that bill to correct some of
the things that are in there should you
choose to adopt some of those things
before it comes to me I would be more
than happy for you to do
that the two things
um the existing law says that you must
maintain a
domicile well RSA 6541 is the statute
that talks about domicile and you can
only have one doile for voting purposes
so changing this in both the the lines
that I have got here line five and line
8 I believe believe it is uh to maintain
your domicile or their domicile when the
actual words in the bill uh is important
to me because I don't want anybody to
can be confused that well I could have a
house over here and I could have a house
over here and as long as one of those
houses that I'm going to call a
domicile you know will get me in that's
not the case all right and if you want
to go back and look at RSA 654 one um
you'll see that it's you can only have
one doile for voting
purposes uh so I do that in both uh
places where we talk about the domicile
that and I add it in there and maintain
that
domicile okay so that you know if a
commissioner you know was elected and
then moved from in our case say from do
to
Farmington okay uh they would no longer
be in in the district and again that
would be against what we're talking
about here the bottom portion uh talks
about what would happen if there's a
vacancy okay and certainly it was our
intent uh that uh this be in effect for
the 2024 elections that you had to live
in the district uh there was only one
person who testified at the uh
commission meeting uh the election law
uh committee uh that said that they knew
that this uh wasn't changed and that
representative lives in Durham uh I
think you can go look up the testimony
if you want uh and did not tell anybody
uh at least didn't tell anybody on my
side of the uh Defence uh that we
neglected to do that uh so we are trying
to make that correction but if for any
reason a vacancy does
exist then we want that person to have
their domicile in the
district okay we are not trying to throw
anybody out of office if you're elected
and you stay elected uh and there's only
one commissioner right now in straford
County who does not live in his district
uh but we'll say uh uh commissioner
Petri one of your former colleagues uh
for some reason uh was no longer able to
serve okay he lives in that District but
if he is replaced certainly we want him
to be replaced with someone who does
live in that district and the chair is
correct that the county uh Commissioners
and the delegations are the ones that uh
would do that um I think it's kind of a
moot point whether or not um you have
just the delegation members from that
District you know should you decide to
change that so that it was that
um I I'm not hard over in either case um
but you know I'll leave that to you and
to the prime sponsor of the bill to
resolve um I I personally don't have any
any
reason um to get very upset I know that
in straford County uh right now because
of the way the delegation is uh there
will be more democratic votes if
everyone does it and Republican votes uh
because that's what the citizens chose
uh it does it would not meet the spirit
of what we were trying to do in having
the people of the district uh elect that
person um but that may also require you
to go out and change other statutes that
we did change in the previous bill so
I'd caution you to to have OS look at
that very carefully uh to make sure that
uh we're not violating something else
that we did um if you have any questions
I'd be more than happy to I'm trying to
get back down to house Ways and Means
Committee
so do any members have a question for
Senator
gray representative
Colby uh just really quick did you um is
the ter term domicile defined within an
Associated statute anywhere again for
voting purposes doile is is defined in
RSA
6541 every inhabitant in the state
having a single established doile for
voting purposes being a citizen of the
United States etc etc etc and since we
are talking uh that it would be the
definition that would be
used further questions representative
Guthrie thank you madam chair thank you
Senator uh for coming and testifying
taking my question would you have any
objection to us
uh uh including your Amendment into our
bill before it goes into the Senate it
was certainly the intent that it be
presented to you uh and I did give
representative turkot a copy just this
morning uh because he seemed to want to
go to Greece or somewhere else it was
causing me some problems and I just got
this back from OLS uh this morning well
we miss them anyway there you go so
again you know what you do is what you
do just so that you know um that the
bill that is in front of you right now
without Amendment um I probably will
submit my own amendment in the Senate if
yes so it is uh I I it is a trism that
we take your Amendment and put it into
our final bill going before the house
you as a courtesy to you Senator uh you
would have no objection I have no
objection thank you thank you mam chair
further
questions seeing none thank you Senator
gray you can go on your way have a good
me next the chair would like to call
Penza welcome to Municipal and County
Government
off oops sorry um thank you madam chair
um my name is representative Kelly Penza
I represent straford District 19 which
is Rochester WS 1 two 3 four and six um
I'm just support here in support of this
bill uh I kind of followed this process
along um when the bill first came out I
believe in 2023 and in 2024 when it all
moved around and all the way up to when
it was at the Battle law
commission uh unfortunately this was uh
an oversight it was a technicality as we
all know uh for people that have uh been
in the house and and for people that are
new um we have a lot of rsas there are a
lot so there a lot of paper that's
pushed around OS and when um you know a
bill is actually you know getting
enrolled and everything that's happening
um
it wasn't looked at in all the places
where it applied to so as you can
imagine for every single state position
in um in New Hampshire so that's from
County Commissioners to sheriffs to
where there's districts to every single
State Rep that is here um you are
running in in in your district and uh so
except for uh straford County
Commissioners right now so it was um it
was something that was not put into the
law uh in a sense a loophole that um
could have been corrected but there
probably would have had to
been um maybe lawyers involved and
things like that and it just wasn't
necessary at that point so um this is
fixing it I'm really glad that Senator
gray put that Amendment forward so I'm
hoping that you guys if you wanted to
maybe save him some time um you could
push that through um just to so you
understand how it affected it there's
three districts in raford County um and
it was affected in specifically in
District um uh where is it District
three thank you um so we actually had uh
one representative that um filed that
was in the district he was in Rochester
War II the gentleman that filed against
him uh with the same party um was in out
of District in do um he should have
actually been filing in District 2 and
then the opposing party on the Democrat
side was actually um out of District as
well so that's what you know that's kind
of what happened and currently we do
have a sitting commissioner that doesn't
represent District um District 3 so
that's kind of where we're at we'd like
to correct this um I do have a question
and I will follow up with the committee
because um it was brought up based upon
what I know right now on the books
there's a conflicting RSA
so for example let's say if that
commissioner um you know fail resigned
or um whatever happened or was you know
trying to be removed um I'm pretty sure
that there's an RSA that says um in
regards with the delegation appointing a
new commissioner that they would have to
reside in the district I know at the
ballot law commission that's how we
argued to try to get this changed in
regards with the filing period stuff so
I will follow up with that because I
think it's important um you know I'm not
sure if that gentleman I hopefully he'll
carry out his whole term and we won't
have to worry about it but if he doesn't
um there is an RSA that actually says
for the delegation that they would have
to be um in District so I think that's
all I have to say if you have any
questions let me know but um I'm just
supporting this um fixing a loophole
unfortunately but thank you
representative
Penza for your testimony
you next I have a pink card for
government thank you uh for the record
I'm Alvin C I represent marac County
District 26 which is a float bual with 8
towns if you really want all the names
I'll give them to you um for this bill
um one of the things that I was
concerned about which uh Senator gray
addressed in his proposed amendment was
for the
um um elected commissioner to maintain
domicile in the
district um so as for for the term is
off
office um the other couple of thoughts I
had was um online uh
13 where it says the vacancies shall be
provided for law uh based on the
2024 uh laws uh I would suggest that
this be provided uh if there's a vacancy
that it would be this paragraph would be
the defining thing so that um any
vacancies is filled is filled with a
person within that
district and for Stafford
County
uh you may want to consider staggering
the Implement implementation of this for
the three districts over uh different
election terms
um possibly just to help alleviate the
situation where you've got one person on
in the district you might want to give
them the
benefit of the doubt that's up to you
it's just a
suggestion uh I'll take questions if
anyone has
any thank you representative C questions
for
him seeing none thank you thank
you next I have a Ms Susan Rice who
wishes to testify on House Bill
78 welcome to Municipal and County
Government
that hello thank you for allowing me to
speak today my name is Susan Rice I
reside at 1591 Rod Road in Rochester New
Hampshire I have followed this bill all
the way through I have also testified at
the ballot law commission the idea was
to bring straford County into
conformance with the other nine counties
within the state of New Hampshire I hope
that you will seriously consider
consider adopting this along with
Senator Gray's Amendment though I will
confess I have not um had the
opportunity to read his amendment in its
entirety um but from what he explained I
think that he addressed several of the
issues in regards to the last speaker
having staggered terms we only have this
issue in District Two And if this is all
passed it's my understanding that it
will be corrected in the
2026 election and then we will be in
full
conformance with what the spirit and
intent and those words spirit and intent
were repeatedly stated by those of us
who testified at the ballot lock
commission thank
you thank you Miss rice questions
you and the final pink card that I have
for this bill is Mr
Brian
chirichello did I get it right pretty
worse thank you madam chair honorable
members of Municipal and County
government my name is Brian Cher chello
um uh I am a former County Commissioner
Rockingham County um also a former State
Rep from 20110 to
2020 uh I am neutral on the bill itself
um however I just wanted to point out
some language as we all know words have
meaning um and I've been trying to work
on this over the last four years on
fixing it um I did hear Senator gray add
an amendment with the word maintain in
there but I would ask that the committee
kind of really do a deep dive into it
and I'll Point your attention to lines
six and
seven and it just basically says a
person must have a domicile in the
district from which he is elected at the
time time of his election at the time of
his election obviously you're going to
change the pronouns but I just want to
share with you what happened in
Rockingham County four years ago before
I became a commissioner the commissioner
who had my seat was in a district
district
three he ended up um getting married to
a female that uh lives in lived in
Portsmouth a whole different
District so he ended up
moving from Derry to pouth opposite
sides of of the
county and when approached we asked him
to resign because he no longer
represented the people of that District
he being a lawyer himself actually
obtained a lawyer and his lawyer said
that those little words at the time of
his
election meant that he got to stay so
here's a county commissioner who lives
in Portsmouth who used to represent
District 3
what we found out was is they were
trying to buy real estate in the in his
old district for transitional
housing and what happened was the
delegation found out I was a member of
the delegation at the time found out
that they were trying to buy this
transitional housing which was between
two elementary schools and the
transitional housing was for uh
releasing prisoners I have nothing
against transitional housing for
prisoners but location means everything
my point being is is how does a county
commissioner who moves out of his
district makes decisions for those
people that voted for him and on a
technicality because he got a lawyer
that said at the time of his election he
lived in Derry that has to change and I
tried changing that four years ago with
uh representative Barbara Griffin but it
was late in the air and we couldn't do
anything so this has been on my mind for
this long as you know I was here 9:00
this morning and I'm the last last one
today so I stay because it's very
important so even though Senator G has
that word maintain still look at that
because they didn't take that that
wording out at the time of the
election um
and if you're concerned about the fact
that if you redistrict you know how
would that work maybe that wording came
in because of redistricting they always
have a language that um that protects
those that are already elected while
redistricting so please take a look at
that and change that that's very
important so thank you very much I I'll
take any questions if anyone has
any thank you Mr chair aello perfect I'm
going to cut the chair will cut in line
and ask the first question um so with
regard to Senator Gray's Amendment you
you you spoke to your concern about the
the phrase at the time of their or his
election or their election so just to be
clear the inclusion in Senator Gray's
Amendment
on line eight of the word maintain is
that sufficient or do you feel we need
to take a second look add extra could
you just clarify that yeah and and I
appreciate representative turot actually
shared the amendment with me because he
knew I had a concern so I would still
look at it because being in the real
estate I that's what I do for a living
real estate maintain could mean a number
of different things
I just don't want to see what happened
to um you know four years ago with that
commissioner really I mean ethically he
really should have stepped down but he
didn't and U again he he used it as a
technicality and it's just
wrong I'm not an attorney I don't
pretend to be an attorney I would just
have someone look at both Senator and I
heard Senator gray say if there's
anything additional he's willing to fix
it as well but just take a look at that
if you don't mind thank you thank you
questions for the
speaker representative Murphy do you
have your hand up
no okay thank you very much okay um that
is the last pin card that I have so I
will ask is there anyone in the room
wishing to speak to this bill who has
not yet had the opportunity to do
so seeing none I will close the hearing
so committee members that concludes our
publicly noticed business for today but
before we adjourn I have a few afternoon
announcements so um looking to next week
so that's the week of um January
19th there is a no there it's not the
week of January 19th okay
so on Monday January SE 16th
it's it's a holiday so
umay
no yeah the 20th I guess I was right
Sunday is the 19th
okay yeah so the 20th is a holiday and
we I plan to meet on Thursday so um be
attentive to your emails for uh a public
meeting notice and then the following
week of January 26th I am looking to
meet on Thursday January
30th if there is no house session and
looking forward into
February the week of February 16th
Monday February 17th is a holiday and I
would like to meet on Thursday February
20th if there is no house session
scheduled um if there is then I'm going
to have to sort something else out and
finally as a reminder the last week in
February the 24th through the 28th is
New Hampshire school winter recess the
speaker has Tena Lively said that he
plans no house sessions and if this
committee is on schedule or ahead of
schedule I plan not to hold a meeting or
if we need to we're I I will hold a
public hearing only so that we can get
our work done so with that um this
committee is ajour Leed thank you and
have a oh sorry questions
yes okay so this is a tenative plan
because this room is a shared res
resource so I plan to meet on Thursday
January
16th no the 19th I'm just having trouble
it's whatever Thursday is I think it's
the
19th
no I I was doing
good it's okay all right the
calendar whatever that Thursday is okay
I must have been looking at something
wrong but so the next tentative date is
30th
no
oh
okay it okay
so I will send out an email that's clear
when I get home any other additional
[Laughter]
questions okay rep thank you
representative
France if we have um County commitments
on Monday how do we handle
that um thank you for the question so
the reason that we're not going to meet
on that Monday which is I believe the
last week in January is because at this
point in time it has been brought to my
attention that I this committee has at
least three members who will not be able
to attend so again we don't have all the
bills referred to this committee so I
need to sort out what our workload is
going to be and whether or not we're
going to have a hearing or a full
executive session or half and half so
it's it's not a good idea to to have it
when I I know at least three people
won't be
here
so that's why it's on
Thursday we can talk offline with
want okay any further
questions okay seeing none again thank
you for participating today and have a